the judge has set the trial date for
Donald Trump in the federal case March
4th the day before super Tuesday
inhibiting Donald Trump's ability to
campaign on the most important primary
day of the election year this is overt
cheating in the 2024 election this judge
is anti-trump she'd already said that
she's surprised he's even free
considering what's going on so we know
where this is going they are pulling out
all of the stops and I think one of the
most damning things to come out from the
story of Trump's indictment in Georgia
is that the only person to be remanded
to custody is the black guy who runs
black voices for Trump we have a poll
that came out from Fox News that says
Donald Trump has 20 support among black
voters now if that's true and it's a
very big if because you know among the
I'd like to see this poll repeated a
hundred times before I believe it but if
that's true according to the Wall Street
Journal and many analysts if the
Republican Party reaches 20 percent
support among the black vote Democrats
cannot win
so this should be pretty interesting and
perhaps that's why the one guy who gets
remanded to custody no bail is the black
voices for Trump director
we'll see how that plays out we're going
to talk about these stories before we do
my friends click the link in the
description below and buy your tickets
to timcast IRL in Miami with Patrick Bet
David Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates
co-hosted by Luke gradkowski I of course
am there is going to be awesome tickets
are available now 714 remain or just go
to timcast.com
and if you'll see in the menu bar
timcast IRL in Miami it's going to be
October 6th we hope to see you there we
got a bunch of Swag Bags to give out
sponsored by Public Square we are huge
Fanatics for Public Square I love what
they're doing if you're not familiar
download the app Publix Square it shows
you a list of businesses and a map of
businesses that share your values so we
can double down on our bicots supporting
companies that share our values and uh
win this culture war and build a
parallel economy also head over to
timcast.com click join us become a
member to support our work directly and
hang out with uh without with all of us
on our members only after show which
goes up just about 10 P.M Monday through
Thursday we've got a particularly spicy
one tonight it's going to be a lot of
fun a bit silly and a bit sad and gross
all of those things because everybody
here knows what the story is already but
it's like well this one's a little too
but we'll save this one for the after
show but you will enjoy it and as a
member who if you've been a member for
at least six months or you sign up at
the 25 a month level you can submit
questions and even call into the show to
talk to us my favorite part of the night
so smash that like button subscribe to
this YouTube channel and take the URL
right now share it wherever you can
because that's the most powerful way to
help literally Word of Mouth helps the
podcast to grow and helps people stay
informed as to what's going on joining
us tonight to talk about this and so
much more we got Spike Cohen hey how are
you doing great to be back absolutely
who are you I am Spike Cohen I'm a
husband a businessman I was the 2020
libertarian candidate for vice president
and I am the founder and president of
you are the power do you know who's
going to be the libertarian candidate
we don't know yet no idea all right well
should be fun thanks for hanging out
thanks man we got Libby Evans okay Tim
how's it going you're you're not Ian
you're Libby I am not Ian I'm Libby I'm
over here yeah uh who are you I'm Libby
Emmons I'm the Editor in Chief of the
post-millennial and human events glad to
be on the show right on and of course
Santa Claus hanging out hey I'm Hannah
brimlow I'm happy to be here with both
of you tonight it's gonna be a fun show
and serge is here
yes I am before I head to Miami to go
prep for this big show so get your
tickets y'all yeah it's gonna be fun all
right everybody let's jump into this
first story we got this from the
post-millennial breaking Trump to appeal
DC trial date of March 4th calling it
election interference I have to agree
there they know exactly what they're
doing setting the state there's no
question about it they sure they try to
stop it I think it was Brian Kemp try to
shut it down in Georgia and now at the
federal level like okay well we're gonna
interfere by any means necessary
former president Donald Trump torched
special counsel Jack Smith as well as
federal judge Tanya chutcon in a new
post he put up on Truth social Monday
just hours after his official trial date
in Washington DC was set for March 4th
2024 the day before super Tuesday Trump
suggested the actions of both parties
amount to election interference and
promised he would appeal the decision
saying
deranged Jack Smith and his team of
thugs who were caught going to the White
House just prior to indicting the 45th
president of the United States an
absolute No-No I like that have been
working on this Witch Hunt for almost
three years but decided to bring its
smack in the middle of crooked Joe
Biden's political opponent's campaign
against him election interference today
a biased trump-hating judge gave me only
a two-month extension just what our
corrupt government wanted super Tuesday
I will appeal he made a follow-up post
saying page two colon
how do you have an indictment that is
based almost entirely on the findings of
the January 6 unselect Committee of
marxists fascists and political hacks
when these same low Lives who have been
caught lying for years about Russia
Russia Russia Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine
fisa at the fake dossier much more
purposely and illegally destroyed and
deleted all of the evidence findings and
proof of the January 6 committee when
will deranged Jack Smith criminally
charge the committee
well there's no question in my mind and
I think any reasonable human being can
understand that when they set the trial
date for the day before super Tuesday
this will inhibit Donald Trump from
campaigning on the single most important
day of maybe even the whole election
because whether super Tuesday is huge
you're going to win the primary but the
votes the turnout we see in the primary
is it reflects the general election
Donald Trump won't be able to have
rallies or if he does it's going to be
at a courthouse
and it's going to give his opponents and
Joe Budden a tremendous Advantage they
know exactly what they're doing change
my mind well here's the thing about it
it's not just that it's super Tuesday
which is 14 States including Texas and
California it's also that they're
seeking to put a gag order on him to not
be able to talk about a lot of what's in
the case
so they already did gag him for some of
the stuff I think anything involving
Witnesses information about that that
comes out pre-trial but who knows if
they're going to file another motion to
try and stop him from having any further
discussions publicly about what's going
on in this case I think that's a really
big concern as well especially when he
comes out saying that it's election
interference they don't like that and
you also have
um you also have a lot of people saying
that his post untruth social constitute
a level of violence like when he says if
they come for me I'm coming for you and
they think that you know like NPR thinks
that that's violence when really what
that is is like also law fair you know
it's like further legal implications
well then that also implies that they're
coming they see they're coming for him
as violence yes of course they do
because they think words are violence as
they think words are violence they've
already told us this right all through
2020 words are violence all the pronoun
people words are violence it's it's it's
it's a ridiculous concept when the when
these far leftists are like words are
violence and then they insult you and
call you a name because by their
definition your response should be what
they describe as self-defense yes which
is violence right you have to go loot
things if you've been insulted you have
to go it's what they do break yeah it's
important no I tend to agree with you I
think he's certain to win the nomination
at this point I I don't see a scenario
in which he doesn't you know pass away
or something like that that doesn't
result in him getting the nomination
this is more about having the pretense
or the pretext to be able to like you
said to gag them to make it where he
can't talk about what promises to be if
not the single biggest election issue
one of the biggest ones while he's
campaigning
well yeah and they just turned over what
like I think uh 12 million pages of
discovery I think that came out today as
well 12 million Pages it doesn't seem
like a real amount it's like when Saddam
says 0.8 million pages of discovery that
the doj have it off in the in the
documents case every third page is just
like a recycled article from like a
1970s playboy or something hoping nobody
notices well that's the thing that's
what Discovery is like a lot of what
they do in Discovery when they don't
want you to do well in your case is they
hinder you by giving you too many boxes
yeah they give you like everything that
they can come up with and they say it's
in here and then you're going through it
all yeah we can't tell you where you'll
you'll find it on your own it's in there
no it's in there yeah whatever it is
it's hard not to think that the gag or
any gag order imposed on Trump would be
broadly interpreted too so even if for
some reason he could be you know at a
campaign rally they're able to say will
you reference the last election which of
course he would because campaigning for
president and they'll say no you're in
violation it seems obvious that they're
trying to trap him into potentially
facing more more charges I'm I'm torn
between whether or not they want him in
jail ill when they want him in jail I
think they do but I don't know if like
these Democratic leaders are in
alignment on when and how
because if Donald Trump went to jail now
it would be a massive boost for his
campaign but it's really hard to predict
exactly what would happen like if they
remanded him to custody
it would inhibit his ability to campaign
but the Press would be so explosive that
it might make more money for it for him
than
he did like seven million dollars off
the Georgia mugshot right and I think
that was like yesterday's number or
something yeah that was yesterday's
number now they they have remanded black
voices for Trump his name's Harrison
Floyd so he cannot campaign campaign and
he's the only one yeah what was their
justification for only they're just lock
up the black guy
you know they wanted to improve the
judicial system is racist I'm surprised
that no one caught that right away
because I remember when I saw the news
that he was being remanded I'm like like
the only guy they were Amanda is the
black dude like he's like 19 people yeah
yeah and then and then I think we
mentioned on the show and everyone
laughs and I'm like well you guys didn't
like I thought everyone just noticed
they did that yeah your Tweet was the
first thing I saw on that and I was like
oh no because Libby doesn't see color
that's the thing but this is like a 4D
chess thing they're saying see we told
you this system is systemically racist
right
we told you we told you that because we
do it yeah because we are racist we know
it well there was that poll uh I saw a
screenshot from Fox News and I didn't
see a headline reflecting that
particular aspect of the story the
headlines were all like Trump improves
and then you can read the poll and see
that Trump is enjoying 20 support among
black voters according to Fox News
I don't believe it
I don't I don't trust these polls
because uh uh but far be it for me to
say outright it is completely wrong Wall
Street Journal I think it was a year ago
found the exact same uh almost the same
thing 17
and uh several months before a month or
two before that found that Latinos and
Asians were also skewing towards the
Republican party and it may not be that
they're skewing towards Republican party
but the left is going absolutely insane
and the Democrats saying things like we
know gas prices are high but sacrifice
for Ukraine kind of drives voters insane
and they're going to be like at this
point I'll vote forever offers me
anything give me a ham sandwich and I'll
vote for you right so I do think it is
possible these numbers are real and
there was a lot of propaganda videos
people put out where it's you know like
black dudes saying like you Imma Be Free
which i i f with Trump man yeah coach
I'm like yeah okay dude like come on you
find a handful of guys it doesn't mean
these polls are real these are fun
videos though they're fun but the reason
I'm skeptical is if this is true Trump
can't lose yeah there was actually
something that came out this would have
been back in like 04 or 05 that said
that if uh black support if everything
else remained equal all other
demographics remain equal if black
Democrat support went below 80 percent
there isn't a single state that they
could win an election a federal election
or a Statewide election
Wall Street General wrote that up uh
referenced it a couple years ago yeah
well and that's why it was so
significant when Trump gained like even
two percentage points between 2016 and
2020 among black voters I mean he is
this was like Edison and Pew research
that found it but he is more likely to
have support from black men than black
women but especially in this you know
four-year Gap that we've had Biden it's
it wouldn't surprise me if he maintained
the the stamina that he had produced in
the four years he was in office it was
funny we had a fresh and fit on the show
on Friday
and uh fresh was telling us that Trump
getting this mug shot is gonna resonate
with a lot of people who felt that
they've been in uh unjustly incarcerated
they're going to see this guy who's
being unjustly incarcerated he's going
to resonate with him he's going to earn
their vote now today I saw this
narrative where they're like how dare
you insinuate this has been coming up
all over the place that I've been
playing with this myself yeah because
Trump was put in jail he'll gain black
support as if all black people have been
in jail and it's like well hold on there
a minute yes hold on they're they're
they are so I can't speak for anybody
else I can just tell you what we talked
about on uh the podcast with fresh and
fit but yo fresh is a black man telling
me this and he was referencing
specifically people who felt unjustly
incarcerated not all black people now I
don't know where the other narrative
like maybe someone said something else
I'm not going to say that that idea came
from this show but people are saying it
and now they're getting offended that
it's racist to imply I suspect he's
going to get at least a little bit of a
boost in Black support if for no other
reason than he created the greatest rap
album cover art ever like
that that mug shot yeah yeah I've been
hearing this from people that it's like
basically racist to say that a mug shot
would engender support in the black
community but by the left's own numbers
right by the Democrats own numbers black
people are but proportionally by
population more imprisoned more
disproportionately yeah
disproportionately imprisoned locked up
you know unjustly treated in the system
and so now they're like you could see
someone else is being unjustly treated
in the system oh just like me and my
brother and whoever else and I think
that it's true like a lot of Americans I
think have been arrested you know most
of the men that I know have been
arrested at some point spend the night
in jail whatever else but look at stop
and frisk the Democrats screamed that
was racist and then when Bloomberg was
made he was challenged as mayor he said
well look where the crime is you know
that's where the Democrat that's what it
says and it's like he's just he's just
saying too bad yeah if the Democrat
if the Democrats are complaining saying
that black people are disproportionately
targeted by police and then someone says
I think that might benefit Trump that is
being he's being uh unjustly you know
charged it's absurd that people like how
dare you but of course Democrats what
else can you expect from them but utter
hypocrisy I think it's the bending of
the logic they'll be like well Trump
could never experience the things other
people could experience like because
he's whatever white and privilege I I
think part of it is you know
as you watch him get buried in all this
legal bureaucracy getting 12 million
documents sent to him people identify
their own challenges with law
enforcement and the legal system right
they just see that like this is not a
system that is meant to give you uh a
swift trial it's not something that
necessarily uh is fair and it's not
necessarily a racial thing so much as
people who find that the system is
broken is seeing that no one is safe
from it trump it was the president of
the United States and they're going to
do whatever they can to try and keep use
this this arm of the government to keep
him out the previous president it could
happen to anyone yeah it is interesting
too that the doj has been trying to
accelerate the timelines and the cases
that they're doing that they're
Prosecuting and Georgia and New York
both seem to be stretching it out a
little bit you know it's like Georgia
and New York want to get convictions
after the doj gets conviction so that
they can use those convictions in their
case even Alvin Bragg got permission to
use Trump's testimony in the E Gene
Carroll case for his falsification of
business documents case which of course
I just want to point out Hillary Clinton
got charged with falsification of
business documents she was fined eight
thousand dollars the DNC paid a hundred
and thirteen thousand dollars that was
for the creation of the Steele dossier
which they classified as legal fees
they got that and Trump's facing it's
multi-layered right they they get one uh
trial date I think uh in Georgia you've
got kind of chaseborough October 23rd
they will use all the testimony from all
of these and they'll keep layering it on
the first mission to inundate Trump's
sphere of influence with legal
challenges that drain their resources
and inhibit them from rallying
campaigning the second of course is to
just put them in jail to get rid of them
and another large component is maybe the
lastly it's get him in jail if we have
to but the other large component is can
we utilize any of this testimony to
remove Trump from the ballot which
brings me to this story oh it's getting
worse from Politico New Hampshire
Republicans Feud over bid to knock Trump
off 2024 ballot the state GOP chair
defended Trump's eligibility on Monday
we also have this from Friday Florida
lawyer files challenge to disqualify
Trump from 2024 race citing 14th
Amendment now that one hit Friday we
know it has begun they're going to try
and file all these legal challenges say
Trump can't be president but this is new
from Politico take a look at this New
Hampshire Republicans have erupted in a
feud over a long shot effort to keep
former president Donald Trump off the
ballot in 2024 with the chair of the
state GOP insisting Monday the front
runner for the party's nomination will
be included in New Hampshire and
elsewhere some legal Scholars and Trump
critics have long argued the former
president should be disqualified from
the ballot under Section 3 of the 14th
Amendment which bars those who've taken
an oath to support the Constitution from
holding office again if they've quote
engaged in Insurrection against the
United States or given Aid or Comfort to
its enemies but the dispute is taking
off in New Hampshire where Bryant Corky
Messner an attorney who ran on Trump's
endorsement
uh and Senate blah blah is questioning
Trump's eligibility for the ballot I'm a
constitutional conservative the word say
what they say I quite frankly believe it
is in Donald Trump's best interest to
get this looked at as quickly as
possible in any effort to keep Trump off
the bat we'll face a steep climb blah
blah blah we get it but here we go
ladies and gentlemen state by state it's
not even 2024 and they're already trying
to remove his name from the ballot if
even a single state removes Trump's name
from the ballot you will have 75 million
people at the bare minimum saying we
never had an election that yeah I would
say that I'm sure you would say that
absolutely I mean 75 million people who
voted for him last time around I can't
imagine that they would consider it a
free and fair election if Trump's name
is taken off a single state Florida
especially if if Trump's name's off in
Florida he can't win especially off
especially prior to a conviction right
like he's being found essentially being
found not guilty being found guilty
before a conviction and I I also think
that's why they're trying to push these
things forward is they're not just
looking at the you know gagging him or
the political consequences of it they're
looking at trying to convict him so that
he doesn't even qualify to run for
president but criminal conviction
doesn't matter because the lawsuit
citing the 14th Amendment is a civil
matter it's a political matter so the
question is does a judge think Trump
waged Insurrection we're not here to you
know the judge is going to say the
question laid before the court is not
whether or not Trump committed a crime
but whether or not he waged Insurrection
based on the evidence from the January 6
committee media report media report
media report right video video it seems
clear the judge says it just says yes
that's it and then it'll get appealed
here's the crazy part
let's just say it's December 12th and it
finally goes to Supreme Court it's
rapidly pushed through and they say we
reject this you cannot remove Trump's
name from the ballot when the election
was a month ago right yeah that's the
concern it's interesting too because and
I'm sure you've seen it the stories out
from the Atlantic New York Times you
know NPR whoever else saying that Trump
should be off the ballot that they
should use this 14th Amendment and then
I was listening to a podcast
um like an NPR Podcast because I'm
always interested to hear what they say
what they say you know and I'll be like
that's not what happened but I'm always
interested to hear it and they were
saying that state like secretaries of
State for each state and Attorneys
General they could make the decision
themselves that Trump was guilty of an
Insurrection and pull his name off the
ballot ballot and they were sort of
encouraging people to do that I will say
though that for the the New Hampshire
thing the New Hampshire GOP chair was on
Charlie Kirk today and was saying that
he talked with the secretary of state
and attorney general and doesn't think
the move against Trump on the ballot is
going to happen but that doesn't mean
that it couldn't happen in other states
and certainly a lot of Democrats are
saying that Attorneys General have the
power to do that what I don't
the Attorney General can unilaterally
just say we take Trump off that's what
they were saying on this podcast I was
listening to today was that they could
that the attorney's General could say
he's guilty of an Insurrection that that
could then be appealed but by that point
like you were saying if he's already off
the ballot then the election
interference has already happened right
right sorry like you have to then
encourage a pencil Campaign which I'm
totally bringing a pencil it won't work
I mean it's going to be an October
surprise right something's gonna happen
they want the legal challenge
to uh to uh to go through
after the after the election yeah that's
right they do it in October you uh early
voting and mail-in voting is happening
and there's no name there's no Trump on
some of these ballots and you know what
it's entirely possible based on what we
saw in 2020
with the executive unilateral changes to
the election rules and things like that
things like in Pennsylvania where they
did Universal mail and voting in
violation of their own Constitution a
lower court judge said yep then the
Supreme Court goes nah it's probably
fine even though any reasonable person
can be like yeah your Constitution says
you can't do this but they don't care
they're gonna do whatever they want I
wouldn't be surprised if come October
they just as you mentioned Attorneys
General just take Trump Trump's name off
and say there is no question everyone
knows he waged Insurrection we've been
talking about it for years using that
exact word yeah and then you have to use
that word right because they've been
saying Insurrection specifically because
of the Constitution yeah and then what
happens is they say if you have a
problem with Sumi
and everyone does and then the
election's over and they say what's the
big deal we had an election
it's like with covid when in New York
state
um Governor Cuomo shut down all the
churches and a suit was brought and it
ended up getting an emergency hearing
before The Supreme Court and the Supreme
Court said no you can't shut down the
churches but that was months and months
and months later and by that point like
most of the people had stopped going to
church altogether and Cuomo said okay
we'll get rid of it and then he did
another one in a slightly different way
that did the same thing because it could
then be challenged again and months
later be ruled to yeah look and I don't
think they brought a challenge at that
point I think they were out of cash I
got it I gotta tell you I don't know
when people start to realize that the
courts have no enforcement power
everything's gonna start breaking down
because it's always it's an interesting
thing right the executive branch has its
enforcement power the judicial uh the
legislative branch has subpoena power
and they can make criminal referrals
it's a bit weaker the executive branches
obviously where most the power is almost
all of it but the uh the courts what can
they do other than bang the gavel and
say do it and of course you know courts
have some degree of enforcement but it's
minimal if a court says something and no
one abide bides it what do you do I I
tell these people when it comes to
private matters too like you know it's
the old sayings a person can be judgment
proof or you can't get blood out you
can't squeeze blood from a turnip I'm
like if you win a suit against someone
like look at Alex Jones right they sue
him for what is it like the entire GDP
of France like no that's what they
requested I think they won like a
billion dollars I'm like you're not
gonna get a penny out of him because you
get in line behind all of his other uh
creditors yeah it's just you you can't
just make these things happen there's no
guarantees
also they're ensuring that he stays on
the air because he's gonna need to stay
on the air in order to earn money to pay
them back oh that's funny too yeah
unless I think they said they want to
destroy him but here's my concern this
is what I was thinking about uh over
this past week
we saw the Chas the chop the George
Floyd
um autonomous Zone we saw the Atlanta
autonomous Zone these things popped up
we saw uh random acts of violence and
now you have on top of the political
violence uh story we'll get to in a
minute a GOP lawyer we don't know what
happened was killed in his home he was
stabbed to death maybe maybe political
maybe not but we'll talk about that but
with the escalation of political
violence that we've been seeing to the
point where Stephen Marsh who wrote the
book the next civil war says we're in
civil strife
at a lingering thought about these
autonomous zones
it's funny to me that so I was trending
earlier on Twitter because you know in
your own category right in my own
category too yeah
and it was people people were talking
about Civil War
it's like oh I said it's a drink and I'm
like it's really interesting you know
honest question uh
if I were to tell you that say like a
president claimed the election was
completely fraudulent large amounts of
his supporters were claiming that he
would he's the true president and but
it's illegitimate there had been a
dispute over who actually won the
election in the previous uh election
cycle as well and then you ended up with
a bunch of people storming into the
capital and fighting with police in
front you also had a roving band of 100
100 plus far left extremists storm onto
Government property in Georgia and in
one instance get into a shootout with
police shooting a cop and then the cops
shoot back killing one of the extremists
you have far left extremists being
arrested and charged overtly with
domestic Terror I'm like at what point
do you say maybe yeah Civil War right my
point is this
all of that stuff it's almost like you
got to keep reminding people uh that hey
this stuff happened I don't know where
it goes from here but yeah far left
extremists took over a government site
in Georgia and opened fire on police
after torching several homes in the area
the police came in and returned fire a
cop was struck and one of the extremists
was killed like yo it's getting crazy
all right yeah that is crazy now imagine
this scenario this is what got me
worried
Chaz Chaz and the George Floyd
autonomous Zone were on public property
the Atlanta autonomous Zone was it was
out of Wendy's but the windows was burnt
to the ground and then everyone kind of
abandoned the area
so we have this uh these different
circumstances what happens a far left
extremists occupy a piece of private
land let's say in uh in Georgia or
Tennessee or something
slightly more conservative leaning area
near an urban environment they occupy to
set up the autonomous Zone on a derelict
piece of private property the person who
owns that property then goes to the
police and says get these whack jobs off
my property and the police say we have
no capability to do that like we saw
with Chaz and George Floyd and Atlanta
the police backed down and we're like
we're not getting involved but what
happens when a private owner or
Corporation says if the police won't do
anything about it I will well you saw
there was a guy in Atlanta who was he
was a landlord he had he owned a home he
was renting it out uh tenants moved out
a couple days later he went to check on
the home and he was met with a guy with
a shotgun a bunch of dogs and some
prostitutes and he was like oh why are
these people in my house he was like you
got to get out of my house the people in
the house the squatters called the
police said that it was their home the
police got the guy you know carted off
it's six months later he's still waiting
for the people to get out of his house
he's still paying the mortgage and he's
stuck he doesn't have a property he
doesn't have any rights apparently there
was also I mean the other thing too is
like it depends on where the government
is do you Remember The Move Organization
in Philadelphia yeah and they were
bombed actually by the city but this was
a group of black nationalists who had a
taking over a little area in
Philadelphia and West Philadelphia
they had purchased a property in
Virginia and they were planning to move
to Virginia get out of the city and
there was a shooting of an officer
officer ramp I think it was in 79 and a
bunch of people like nine people ended
up getting arrested and put in prison
for that they were called the move nine
um and so they decided to stay and by
staying what ended up happening is the
mayor of Philadelphia who was a black
mayor is it Wilson good am I remembering
that correctly I don't know anyway he uh
coordinated with the FBI and bombed they
fire bombed they fire bombed it and as
people were trying to run out they shot
them yep it was like Waco at a
neighborhood level right yeah and it was
a response to a legitimate issue right
but they basically declared war on the
neighborhood yep and they burned down
houses like not just the move compound
but they burned down houses in the area
as well you know that's uh
when the government was more uh had
stronger Monopoly on their violence but
the government was in control of the
violence at that point and that's not
the same now right and so now my concern
is what happens if another Chas happens
but it happens on like
abandoned property not even a band of
derelict is a better way to put it like
someone owns it and they're like let's
say a corporation you know Nordstrom
just shut down in San Francisco which is
like a big deal that is a big deal the
mall is still owned right I think the
the building was uh forfeited by the uh
by Westfield to the bank
so okay
let's say large corporation owns three
acres of of land somewhere and the far
left decides we're gonna take it and no
one can stop us
cops aren't going to go engage in a
shootout no they're gonna ignore it not
in an abandoned Mall not even abandoned
mall like let's imagine it's just like a
an old Warehouse building that's not
being used but it's still on the books
for some big Corporation or moderately
sized let's say like medium local or
like Corporation in the city that's got
like a few board members and maybe a
couple hundred employees so it's small
enough but big enough the far left
decides we're gonna take it because it's
not being used it's got broken windows
and graffiti all over but the people who
own it are still keeping track of it and
then what happens when the police are
like
we're not going to do anything not on
city property we're not going to get
involved this is why the Second
Amendment and the right to keep and bear
arms for self-defense is so important
like we've seized over and over again
with Chas and with chop with Uvaldi and
with Parkland like when the police have
mandated that everyone is vulnerable to
violence and that you know they're the
Monopoly on violence they very often
like kind of hang back and in a way you
almost can't blame them because they
also want to get home to their families
but they were holding back parents that
were trying to get in there right in
Uvaldi the guy who actually went in uh
to uh to kill the Uvaldi shooter he was
an off-duty border patrol agent who
ignored their orders not to go in there
and this is the most horrifying story
it's it's horrific and and the case you
were talking about the man in Atlanta he
was trespassed right he was actually
arrested until they realized he was the
property owner it's at some point people
need to realize you are your own first
responder all the old cliche stuff our
parents said about when when seconds
count the police are minutes away
they're they're minutes away to possibly
holds you back as people victimize you
and so we really need to understand just
how Paramount the right to self-defense
is it's sort of terrifying I mean I I
have like tried to avoid interactions
with police my entire life like when I
was a kid at one point there were police
in my in my house and I was like I'm not
gonna repeat this this is never
happening yeah yeah you know but it's
like it's very scary when you come into
contact with police because they show up
and they think everybody is the enemy
head on a swivel yeah yeah
I mean well think about it this way
remember they killed that Australian
lady there was uh so you guys saw that
video where the um was like Extinction
Rebellion people or whatever have the
barricades and and yeah is that by
burning man yeah it was all the people
trying to get to Burning Man and the
climate activists were blocking the road
well the cops apparently got a call that
someone had a gun I guess what happened
was someone told the police you need to
get down here and clear this barricade
before someone shoots one of these
protesters something like that then what
happened is the dispatcher says to the
police there's concerns about a
potential shooting we've got protesters
yeah so then the cops think these
protesters have guns and when the cop
Rams the barricade and jumps out with
his gun he says where's the gun several
times something like that I think that
I'm pretty sure it could be wrong but
think about it from the perspective of
cop all you know is you got a call from
dispatch saying two people are fighting
inside this house it's getting ugly we
need someone to come and shut this down
and then you show up and there's a group
of people in the house being like get
out of our house and some guy that's my
house like what do they do yeah they
typically just say civil matter have a
nice day right like the Tracy Chapman
song the uh the Nevada thing was
absolutely amazing though because you
had climate activists blocking the road
you had Burning Man people trying to get
through the road and then you had Tribal
Police show up yeah to clear the road so
the climate change people think they're
on the side of the Tribal Police they
think that they're on the same side as
them The Burning Man people think
they're on the side of the climate
change people but it turns out they're
not meanwhile the Tribal Police are the
ones who get like all they have all the
oppression points so they're the ones
who get to win and then they show up as
a bunch of guys in trucks with guns
we did have a bunch of upper middle
class white people occupying native land
right and that's one thing they said
you're trespassing on tribal land it's
one thing the cop said to these people I
want to jump to this story this is from
NBC Boston
GOP activist and lawyer stabbed to death
in his Durham New Hampshire Home full
stop
we have no idea what happened it's
entirely possible that this guy had a
bad poker game and then somebody got mad
at him no idea he could have been
cheating on his wife and then she comes
home and says Ah and then they fight and
then she stabs him we have no idea
however
not knowing the issue is typically that
whenever we get a news story about a
victim who is left with no no no let me
stop I'll put it this way when Jesse
Smollett comes out and claims some guys
threw a noose around his neck the whole
world shuts down every television
network runs a tribute you get uh at the
time Ellen Page saying
like frantically randomly because some
guy hate crime hoaxed all of us
and then when you get a story about a
GOP lawyer being stabbed to death it's
like well you know we don't know exactly
so let's move on from this that's why I
think this story matters because maybe
people on the right be it post-liberal
libertarian whatever you want to call
yourself should start saying when these
things happen we make the Assumption in
the worst until we learn otherwise
because they went balls to the wall for
Jesse Smollett so how about we say we
demand answers as to what happened to
this GOP lawyer who got stabbed to death
in his own home the police are claiming
was self-defense I'm sorry it's going to
be difficult for you to convince me and
it's possible that a person in his own
home was killed in self-defense by a
different person it's possible you know
you invite someone to your house and
then you have the intent of hurting them
they defend themselves it can happen
but still
lawyer in his own house stabbed to death
I'm not leaning towards self-defense
here but I don't know everything I don't
know
it's hard because they're like no
arrests made we're 12 hours out there's
one article up from a local news station
saying they've identified the person
involved but they haven't decided what's
going on I mean
the longer there are no answers in
communication the more suspicious it
gets the easier it is to let sort of the
conspiracy theory run wild uh the day
after Jesse smell like this has been a
week the day after Jesse's Millet how
about uh the Bubba rope incident right
the NASCAR thing it is national news
headlines everywhere and now we have
this story and and everyone's been like
well you know hold on there a minute you
know we don't know for sure and it's
which is the reasonable take exactly
like this is how everyone should respond
to stuff like this exactly let's find
out the facts no exactly that's why I
said in the beginning for all we know we
got a bad poker game yeah but I think
the issue here is
I I'm gonna lean towards you know the
back of my mind political
because when it comes to instances of
mass tragedies and the perpetrators
left-wing they disappear
whenever the bad guy whenever the person
committing the crime happens to fall
into the alignment of the corporate
narrative it's like oh can't have that
one getting out and the story vanishes
I'm just gonna say that yeah the main
festos yeah that's right or how about uh
the guy who rammed the Christmas parade
in uh uh Waukesha and then it was just
like no idea a truck did it a truck
crashed into these people in the literal
same city where the Kyle Rittenhouse uh
shootings happened no that was Kenosha
okay so but but I think they were
triggered by the same couple days after
uh because we were in Austin at the time
and we it was actually writtenhouse had
just gotten I think within 48 hours so
they were right next to each other they
posted uh uh the guy had had some like
BLM related stuff on his Facebook page
but also he had like crashed his car
into his like child's mother before
driving to the the parade I mean
obviously it was a very unstable person
who represented trying to get a sandwich
remember yes and he represented himself
at trial which was something to behold
did you see that trial oh I watched a
lot of it covered up for the site the
patience that judge had I thought that
judge should get him I mean because part
of it was like he just kept interrupting
like you're saying you know when you
don't believe in what the courts are
ruling you can kind of defy them it also
turns out that if you don't want to
follow the procedures of the Court it is
challenging to enforce uh anything and
also ensure the person who's
representing himself gets a fair trial
he had to keep getting sent to the to
another room to watch virtually and then
it's a question of like can he
accurately represent himself uh this is
a tan this is an aside but you know the
in the case of this lawyer what's hard
is like either way loss of life very sad
you know the police in this town are
saying there's no threat to the public
so that's sort of playing I I actually
think it's leaning towards domestic
violence
but like it is Extreme really difficult
I totally get you don't want to jump the
gun and blow something up that you're
giving the police a chance to accurately
investigate on the other hand it is hard
to say this is a pretty a fairly
prominent political figure in a state
it's the first the nation to primary so
we kind of need some information here as
soon as possible and and this past week
the GOP was arguing over whether or not
to remove Trump from the ballot so I I
don't care to give anyone the benefit of
the doubt and my bigger concern is as a
reasonable person you're right domestic
probably seems like what this may be the
person who had identified may be a
significant other and that's why they're
like oh my God and they're saying
self-defense like who else would be
right yeah who else would be defending
themselves in this guy's right not a
visitor but someone who actually lives
there as well uh that being said if the
uh Freedom faction of individuals
whatever you want to call that uh the
anti-establishment faction does not get
serious in their propaganda game they
lose and I don't mean to just lie I mean
to make noise at the very least when on
the merits of being reasonable that's
why I opened the segment by saying
probably a bad poker game who knows but
be noisy enough about it to force the
conversation
because in the event that there is uh
and there have been like Aaron Danielson
for instance someone shot and killed in
the streets of I think it was Portland
right it was uh Portland by a far left
extremist Michael reinol these stories
need to get Max attention when Andy Noe
was mercilessly beaten and attacked with
the concrete milkshakes in in uh was
that Portland as well right yeah uh that
forced even Brian stelter to say okay
you know we got to talk about this
because it's like going massively viral
those images everywhere attention needs
to be brought to it and those are those
are the victories where you can start to
to convince these regular people who
don't pay attention
there's something going on here and I'll
give it I'll give a specific example
Oliver Anthony right he gets really
really big he issues these statements
after the fact like why is Fox News
playing my video haha it's about them he
says it's not about politics it's not
because he does not know what the
culture war is everything he sings about
and he's a good avatar for this
everything he sings about representing
Working Class People is effectively a
right quote-unquote culture War right to
position but then he doesn't understand
because he's not involved deeply in it
so in the media attacks him and calls
him conservative right wing and the left
says everything he's like no no it's not
left or right I don't know what you're
talking about it's just my lived
experience well he didn't even have a
Twitter account until August you know
and now here he is and that's my point
these regular people you go to them they
don't understand the depravity and the
evil of the uniparty neocon neolibs all
of these warmongers and this garbage
they don't get it the Jessie Smollett
stuff the woke corporations they think
well you know I'm gonna be somewhere in
the middle but they don't pay attention
and then when you actually engage and
you say something like look I'm not here
to argue about policy or anything like
that but it is true that Joe Biden fire
got that prosecutor fired while
threatening to withhold a billion
dollars as soon as you say that you're
right wing my favorite thing is when he
said you got money for Foreign Wars you
can't feed the poor it's like that's a
right-wing talking point because the
left says sacrifice for Ukraine right
it's like you're in the politics dude my
point is normies don't get it and if
you're loud enough and we bring up more
stories like this and we question these
things maybe they might start to see
more of the of the issue all of no go
ahead no Bible Oliver Anthony is kind of
the personification of what Pericles
said long ago which is you may not be
interested in politics but politics are
interested in you and we're seeing that
this is a guy who you know writes songs
and he did one about his frustration
with how things are going and it was I
mean there was a political element to it
but the guys clearly does not want to be
political uh and it seems like the rest
of his songs aren't political to speak
of and he's been thrust into this into
this political battle he didn't want to
be a part of and you know I
a part of me wants him to just be able
to just be a guy who's making songs
unfortunately he's being dragged into
something he didn't even want to be a
part of which speaks to what you're
talking it's because there is a culture
war no you do not exactly as you
mentioned Pericles I think he said right
uh you may not be interested in politics
politics is interested in you there's
nothing you can do about it we're in a
culture War if we were if it was 20 30
years ago you can say I don't care for
Democrats or Republicans leave me alone
and people might be like okay I get it
today doesn't matter the moment he said
minors on an island somewhere far right
yeah that was it and then they started
accusing him of being q-anon and he's
like I'm not political that song's about
Joe but Joe Biden's the one funding the
Foreign Wars and at the very least while
there are many Republicans who want war
there are many who don't yeah so there's
a debate happening over there and not
one happening over there it is clearly
about more about one side than the other
the other thing too I mean you were
talking about 20 years ago the culture
war and it's like 20 years ago is about
when um Arts artists and art
programs and all that kind of thing
started saying that you have to be an
art activist and politics started being
really infused into art programs which
is when I was in grad school and that's
what it all turned into like I was
studying theater and the next thing I
know it's not about telling a good story
it's not about making something
beautiful it's about infusing your work
with political narrative so that started
there and it's been pushing out this
whole way and now we see you know like
Oliver Anthony can't get a song out
without it being part of the culture War
but like also you kind of need to know
where your where you're squatting down
you know what I mean like take a look
around yeah I I I right I gotta
completely agree with that the dude uh
it's an awesome song I I love Richmond
north of Richmond obviously everybody
loves it because it's good
but the dude is he personifies in many
ways a regular person and I mean this
with no disrespect no like literally
just right yep seeing a lot of these
problems we can all kind of identify
while being lied to by the corporate
press he did criticize them for it but
my criticism back is my dude you must
pay attention you must recognize who
your enemies are and who your friends
are and I'm not saying the Republicans
are your friends by no stretch of the
imagination Nikki Haley was up on stage
screaming lies about Putin wanting to
invade NATO so she can justify her in
saying warmongering yeah Republicans are
mostly bad as well but
you need to recognize who will come
after you when you say something like
miners on an island somewhere right it
is going to be the politicians who are
on that plane who are typically aligned
with the establishment and their
corporate allies
well and this is I mean this comes down
to another way of saying you may not be
interested in politics but politics is
interested in you is you may not be
interested in democracy but democracy is
interested in you when more and more
decisions that are being made aren't we
aren't allowing individuals to make them
we're democratizing them what happens is
that means that someone has to win which
means everyone else has to lose and the
people that lose have the winners
opinion enforced on them whatever that
thing is so it becomes less and less
about I disagree with how you live or
what your opinion is you disagree about
it but we're living separately it's one
of us has to win so now someone that you
disagree with is your enemy and so of
course the culture war is only going to
get worse and worse as things are more
centralized and democratized and the
answer obviously is the opposite
decentralization allowing individuals to
make their own decisions
that was one of the things I liked about
Oliver Anthony's rise was that it comes
from a kind of growing area of music I
mean it wasn't from I don't know where
music is headquartered in in the US I
guess Hollywood and Nashville depending
on what you're doing yeah it's sort of
this this other alternative for music
that's getting popular right now I think
there is a desire to decentralize our
sort of cultural uh cap zones but it's
very difficult because I think that's
not what uh the system to give it a
broad term wants you to do well it's the
I think the art forms that are the most
accessible for decentralization are
comedy and music you know and so I think
that that's in part why we're seeing
um more Counter Culture people coming
out in music and comedy but we're not
seeing that as much in film you know it
takes an awful lot of money to create an
independent film or a series you know or
a theater performance or or if you're an
actor if you get that black ball in your
file like no one's going to want to hire
you that's why I think we were all there
on strike now which I actually think is
a boon to culture I think that's a great
thing that all of these people are not
right now being paid to create garbage
that we have to like stuff in our faces
or it's stuffed in our faces rather you
know yeah let's uh let's jump to this
next story because with all the talk
about trying to stop Donald Trump and
get his name off the ballot there's
another strategy that may be coming ABC
News has this one President Joe Biden
says he will request more funding for a
new coronavirus vaccine President Joe
Biden said Friday that he's planning to
request more money from Congress to
develop another new coronavirus vaccine
as scientists track new waves and
hospitalizations Rise though not like
before
okay well what does this mean on its own
maybe not so much maybe something we
also have this
schools close bring back mask mandates
over the rise of covid-19 cases I think
we got another one here
citing Rising covet cases these U.S
Hospital Systems have now reinstated
mask mandates
yeah you know it's it's really worrying
to me that um for the first time in
human history a virus is not uh we've
got seasonal viruses but now we're
dealing with an election seasonal virus
which is particularly worried crazy yeah
but uh as always how does it know how
does it know well it's just you know
it's because as more people start
Gathering to uh to Rally this virus
spreads you know all people are going to
these political arrests so it's not only
political rights well right makes sense
if it knows the in-person Voting is
coming And So It prepares but if you're
you know rioting it doesn't mind it's
not affected by that oh they're all
wearing masks yes that's so Riders were
wearing masks I mean but literally the
writers were wearing masks they didn't
want to be seen either no they didn't
want to spread the virus could you say
that well of course as always as always
I will stress uh don't take medical
advice from podcasters and talk to your
doctor about what's right for you that
being said
uh it's kind of hilarious that all of
these different preparations are being
being made and it would seem that
another lockdown or heavy mandates are
about to unfold so I'm also not a doctor
I'm just a Jew on the internet but uh
and I can see where the confusion would
come but there's something that that
Biden said uh during that when he was
talking about uh the the new uh vaccine
that they're going to get funding for a
vaccine that works it's let me read the
quote yeah let me read the quote quote
this is from ABC News back off YouTube
I signed off this morning on a proposal
we have to present to to the Congress a
request for additional funding for a new
vaccine that is necessary comma that
works what is that implication Mr
President now is not the time to be
sowing any kind of anti-vaccine
conspiracy theories okay
why is noted anti-vaxxer Joe Biden not
trusting the science I don't you know
Korean Pierre is just like do I say that
he mixes up his words sometimes or would
I say he was misquoted like how do we
spin this right now make no mistake that
didn't happen
he said he added that's true gas light
until you win he added that it's
tentatively recommended that everybody
get it once the shots are ready it
doesn't exist we have to pass it before
you can find out what happens when you
inject it like it that's literally no
you don't need to test vaccines I don't
know what you're talking about it hasn't
even been developed yet but you have to
take it yeah because this time it will
work and again this is Joe Joe Biden who
is also not a doctor is
she's a doctor of education but it's not
really a doctor it's called something
else is it yeah
it's not a PhD it's called something
else I'm pretty sure she has her PhD no
no it's not a PhD it's something else
it's not she doesn't even have a
doctorate it's it's an educational
doctorate is called something else
listen whatever she is if she tells me
that the thing that hasn't even been
invented yet I have to take it then I
have to trust her because she does call
herself a doctor well because she did
recommend it for everybody would you did
you figure out what it is she was a
doctor in education but it's not saying
it's not it's not a pH
I'm looking oh it's an ed HD or
something right yeah it is yeah yeah but
they're saying she can still use the
term doctor they're really mainstream
media is really defending her ability
they really want her to be able to use
it I think that's why she got the PHD Dr
Jill Biden just deserves her title what
she has an EDD okay or an at d right
educational doctorate okay so a
doctorate yes
sorry sorry I don't even uh whatever I
don't know what philosophical doctor is
that what a PhD is yeah yeah that is so
stupid anyway yeah credentialism
she slap slap a title typically Dr
Hannah what were you saying that's me
thank you Doctor it was not a medical
doctor but he's a philosophical doctor
no I think he's a doctor of podcasting
that's true
announce the creation of Tim Cass
University and the uh uh granting of the
PHD to Libby thank you and no one ever
said my University was accredited but
nobody asked and I tentatively recommend
to everyone enroll in this because this
is a university that's going to work
okay but in all seriousness it's
decentralized here's my here's my
question to YouTube
this vaccine doesn't exist yet are we
allowed to question it are you allowed
are you alive you're posing a really
great moral and philosophical question I
can't wait for your course on this the
coming fall term are you allowed to
question a vaccine they have not yet
invented I don't know I guess Democratic
method look at this this is perfect
[Laughter]
future science that's right yeah but now
back to the politics do you guys think
they're gonna lock everybody down
I don't and here's why the environment
well let me rephrase that I think there
are some areas some of the the more
Bluer and more uh I guess more
metropolitan areas might have limited
restrictions I don't think we're going
to see the kind of lockdowns we saw
before because that required an
environment of people that this was a
brand new thing that they were horrified
at I remember when I made my first
anti-lock Down video in March of 2020
and I was being attacked by Libertarians
many as many Libertarians who were
saying well we don't know how serious
this is maybe we should you know maybe
we should they're scared wait and see
they were scared people were
legitimately and understandably in the
apocalypse I mean come on everyone was
comparing it to the movie Contagion sure
and the thing is had it been that I
still would have been against lockdowns
because only an idiot would have gone
out outside you wouldn't have needed to
mandate it but it created an environment
where average everyday people were like
you know what let's at least give it a
couple weeks I don't know let's give it
a couple months I don't think that
happens this time I mean we're we're it
covet never went away and everyone's
just like you know what we now know what
it is we know like our relative you know
risk tolerance and so forth we're going
to live our life kind of doing what
we've been saying from all along if you
don't feel well stay home and if you
think you're a high risk tolerance then
adjust accordingly and if you don't then
adjust accordingly I I don't think
lockdowns are going to be something
they're going to be able to do well and
even fauci had some has thrown on the
word endemic right it's harder to get
people to to lock down for something
that they've been living with for
several years and have figured out how
to manage right like I don't really hear
people saying like well you have to test
before you come to my wedding or
whatever anymore I also have this theory
that they actually don't want full-blown
lockdowns because that means that kids
would have to go back to online
schooling and that really drove a surge
in homeschooling right because it
uncovered all these things where parents
were mad because we got to see like
that's like it was when my son was doing
virtual learning that I realized that
they were having a two-day course on uh
what was it white privilege and systemic
racism and I got my voice recorder ready
and I lined it up and I like feel like
we're taking this class together the
whole thing for like the two days of
that that's one my son was like Mom our
whole family is racist and I was like
incorrect no no not actually also a
Democrats president and they don't want
massive job losses so I mean there's
that as well I I don't I don't see and
they can't and if they had to pay
everybody to stay home they'd have to
pull money from Ukraine and we already
know that zielinski's asked us and
Europe to fund the next election or they
do like they did in 2020 and 2021 and
just print out like 40 of all the
currency that were created amazing and
so where we already have high inflation
in a year or so later now you're looking
at 15 20 official inflation and probably
closer to 25 unofficial you guys I just
I don't see that happening I do they're
they're pushing these Mass mandates and
I think it's a lot of it is like how far
can we push government is a habitual
line stepper it is this constant like
how much can I make people do what I
want them to do but I think they realize
that the lockdowns even with people
people as scared as they were they
turned up the the boiling water a little
too hot for the Frog to tolerate they've
kind of gone back and I think now
they're going to do these like kind of
smaller thing like well can we get a
mask mandate but just in you know the
more blue areas is that going to work
how far can we push I don't see
lockdowns happening we were talking
about this before and I said I think
that they'll do guidelines
recommendations recommendations guidance
remember guidance that gives them
ability to roll out universal mail-in
voting and oh that's not happening no
that's happened but they'll have an
excuse now they'll say well we're not
gonna we we can't lock everything down
because the economy you know so we're
going to recommend people quarantine
we're gonna recommend masks and we're
going to recommend vaccines and
obviously for those that have decided to
quarantine which is the right thing to
do we're gonna send you a mail-in
mail-in vote so then what they do is
they just say we're going to send
everyone a mail-in vote because we're
not going to spy on you and see who's
choosing to quarantine and who's not and
that'll be their justification We're Not
Gonna spine you right now but we will
other times we are spying on you but
we're not going to admit that we're
explaining
yeah they're spying on everybody that's
nice in the in the new update I think it
would be hard to get certain states to
lock down especially Governors that are
ambitious politically having seen
basically desantises rise because of his
stance against the lockdowns yeah I
think you would maybe get a couple blue
Governors who are like this is a morally
correct thing to do but for the most
part they know it's it's essentially a
political death sentence they got to do
something because uh Trump's going Trump
lost I I love the never trumpers and
they're like Trump can't possibly win so
he lost by 42 000 votes in three states
he just needs to win these swing States
that's the key right now the country
it's Georgia Arizona and Wisconsin is
that what I think you talked about those
three yeah Michigan I think it's
Wisconsin
Michigan he won Michigan in 2016 but it
was by a sliver yeah and then they got
Whitmer no but uh someone want to look
up what the margins were in 2020. we
know what they were in Georgia
780. right I think in uh in Michigan it
might have been like 20 000 or something
I could be wrong someone will look I'll
look it up yeah uh look I think Trump
can recover in any one of these states I
think Trump might could even get a
couple percentage points of of the
popular vote and the reason is
you know you get all these people that
think 2020 was stolen because fraudulent
ballots and double counting and things
like that it's like okay sure fine maybe
whatever prove it uh maybe you're right
I think the real issue was actually
simple everyone was locked in their
house and the mail and votes arrived
it's just a really simple equation lock
everyone inside house mail them ballot
blame Trump then knock on their door and
say can I have that ballot back please
now if there's no lockdown they'll go
knock on the door and let's say the
failure rate here is only seven percent
let's say 93 of the doors they knock on
someone is home
and we'll fill out the belt and give it
back a seven percent drop Trump wins
even seven percent we saw that from the
story about
um Donald Trump and the hunter Biden
laptop story that if uh what what did
they say it was like 17 wasn't it 17 no
it was it would have changed that vote
if they had known about the laptop and
that accounted for they said something
like if seven percent of people did not
vote Democrats or switched over Trump
trump wins I think it was less than
seven it was like a lot less because it
was a 42 000 in these a few States
if the Democrats lose
a small fraction of the people who are
locked in their houses they can't win I
don't care what the popular vote is even
if Trump could or couldn't get it the
electoral vote they they're not going to
be able to secure not to mention you
know the economy is bad and then you
know what let's do this I have this uh
this video I want to pull up for you
that's going viral Ian miles Chong uh
has this tweet life is hard and it's
getting harder for the middle class I'll
just play a little bit of this clip for
you guys
seriously my bills alone are three
thousand dollars a month I'm a single
mom who receives like 300 a
month in child support for two kids
I can't do this anymore
I work every single day I get maybe a
day off sometimes if I'm lucky I'll get
two days off
I'm sick of it I'm so sick of this
and I forgot to pay my
daughter's braces and now I have to
bring her in for them to remove them
because I can't afford to pay it all off
at once
I am so sick of this country I'm so sick
of how expensive everything is
something needs to happen and that's
something is Donald Trump no I'm half
kidding uh but maybe if you uh to this
to this woman and not personally but in
general
the economy was really really great in
2019. it was nice I went uh I love
telling the story went to a furniture
store we were starting the podcast this
is like January this is this is January
of 2020. and uh starting to pass that
rule and I said uh I'd like to buy some
furniture we need a table that we can
sit at and so we bought a table and the
woman who was doing the sales was really
excited as she wrote up the five
thousand dollar ticket for all the crazy
stuff we were buying to build a studio
and uh she was laughing she was like she
was like thank you so much she's like
wow she's like I gotta be honest it's a
really great day for me you walked in
and just bought it on the spot and I was
like well we know we needed it you guys
had it we had checked it out before and
she was like man it's just been going
really good for me and I was like what
happened she goes this has been the best
year of my life she's like I've never
made more money we had a contractor
doing work for the for the studio and he
said I've never made more money in my
life it's been absolutely fantastic then
covet hits
Trump loses now you have Biden and all
the ramifications that came with kovid
which was both Republicans and Democrats
and now you have these people under Joe
Biden saying I hate this effing country
I'm sick of how expensive everything is
it's like okay
let me show you another story
let me see if we have it here from uh no
it's not there here we go from the
post-millennial Washington power company
raises rates to cover increased expense
due to climate legislation AG's office
instructs them not to tell consumers
reason for higher prices Keith
came
goes on stage and says that the the the
climate change agenda the anti-carbon
agenda is the wet blanket on the economy
it's right there in your face so if
you're wondering why it is that you are
struggling blame the Democrats and the
far leftists and the people who are
trying to shut down energy but hey don't
let me just give a free pass to
Republicans I'm not a big fan of them
either but if you're coming and
advocating for a carbon neutral energy
policy and then telling us we can't have
nuclear energy I say F off you're a liar
because they are a liar because nuclear
energy is the cleanest most efficient
power it's also the most carbon neutral
one so like from their own talking point
of the most important thing more so than
anything else is that the energy that
we're getting is as carbon neutral as
possible nuclear energy per kilowatt
hour is exponentially more carbon
neutral uh than than the so-called
Renewables are we also have an issue too
where nuclear energy is something that
we can generate here in the United
States whereas solar on a generator
do that we're like solar and wind we
have to go buy all that stuff from other
countries import it over here using
fossil fuels of course for our boats and
whatnot yeah it's also the safest form
of energy production nuclear is yeah so
yeah the Boomers for that because this
is 100 the Boomers yeah because like
there were there were nuclear weapons
they freaked out because they had to
hide under their desks in the 1950s as
school children and then they took over
the world and decided to delete
everything that was worthwhile it's your
fault Dad it's the whale's fault it's
the wheels if we were only still using
weight yeah I was gonna say I want to
hear this there it's the whale's fault
and I can explain okay sweet delicious
whale you know if only I'm kidding uh
I've actually had whale before it's
disgusting and I don't recommend it
seems greasy uh I was really looking
forward to that theater no no it is I'll
explain it okay uh so Greenpeace right
they were concerned about nuclear tests
that were being done uh in the ocean the
initial purpose of Greenpeace is my
understanding was to stop these nuclear
tests so they would get their little
boat and they would go and sit in these
areas where they want to do nuclear
tests and then they were like we can't
do it because they're there and part of
the reason was that it was devastating
to whale populations it saved the whales
one of the co-founders of Greenpeace
broke off and formed sea Shepherds to
protect whales so this initial activism
to stop nuclear weapons from Greenpeace
transformed into a desperate well now
that we stop something that's bad how
can we squeeze the tea and milk all
these other morons for their donations
and Greenpeace went from let's stop
nuclear bombs into how can we lie to
people to keep maintaining our facade of
environmentalism they now just say
whatever stupid garbled nonsense they
have to to trick morons into giving them
money one of those things is that
nuclear power is bad and they Revel in
it because they make lots of money from
it it's a cash game and it's beautiful
profit and going back to what Libby said
it all started with their opposition to
nuclear weapons testing so this would be
like opposing solar panels because of
melanoma or something like that like it
has nothing to do with it it's literally
it is what and in fact uh the reason
that we tend to use the less efficient
hard water reactors is because the U.S
government and other governments
prioritized the production of nuclear
weapons over actual energy production
whereas newer forms of nuclear energy
production like uh thorium salt reactors
and things like that are far more
efficient uh the half-life than the the
half-life of the of the waste only lasts
like I think like 100 years instead of
tens of thousands of years I've been
reading about that in every way it's
better it's meltdown proof I'm not going
to try again I'm not a scientist I'm
just a Jew but I I I in every way it's
even safer than nuclear which is already
exponentially safer and better than
everything now we've got the Advent of
fusion which uh I believe they've
already reached an ignition big stories
now they've actually they're trying to
figure out how to actually capture the
energy from the ignition process
miniature Sons I guess uh that's going
to kick off an energy expansion by which
human rights has never experienced and
we are going to we Elon Musk we need you
rapid energy expansion if I don't know
the actual numbers for what Fusion the
exponential increase in energy output
that we'll get from Fusion relative to
fossil fuels but the uh I believe
nuclear is the most efficient I believe
correctly the highest energy output that
we have yeah uh it's remarkable it's
carbon neutral and it's got a massive
energy output and they won't do it so uh
I watched this really amazing little
mini documentary on energy it starts
with human energy we eat food convert
that food into kinetic energy through
our muscles the sugars and we build
things we then figured out hey this big
you know creature over here can pull it
for me and say strap it to a cow made
the cow pole it's animal energy then we
started burning wood then coal we get
petroleum all of these rapid expansions
of energy extraction rapidly increase
human population technological
development Etc
once Fusion kicks off if we get to that
point where we've got Fusion reactors
everywhere we need spaceships and we
need a fast well and that's the whole
point right the whole point of humanity
to a large degree anyway is to create
more stuff to go faster to go further
right so you could look I mean people do
they look at the history of humanity as
the history of energy consumption and
energy creation and we do that and so
like we hit fossil fuels which was great
which elevated so many millions of
people out of poverty globally and now
we're asking the entirety of humanity to
take a step backwards by using less good
energy resources instead of exploring
and developing better ones nuclear is
the way to go forward or this you know
this other Fusion thing right it's the
way to go forward that's how we get to
other planets and that is of course the
goal is to like keep going whether or
not we go to other planets can be your
opinion whatever we can simplify this
for the average person explorers right
but I just want to say this for the
average person says bro I don't care
about Mars I don't care about Venus I
don't care about Neptune or Alpha
Centauri or whatever whatever I just
want to know why I can't buy bread you
can't buy bread because they are putting
a wet blanket on the economy they could
build nuclear they ain't gonna do it
they want to shut down your fossil fuels
without giving you an alternative
because the real answer the real reason
they're doing is probably communism and
so they want to restrict what you can do
control what you can do and you suffer
because of it keep voting for them look
I don't blame this lady who's talking
about her kids and the hardship she's
dealing with because everyone's dealing
with that I don't blame the working
class for being exploited but to a
certain degree I beg of these people to
pay attention it's why it's so important
when people are like I don't pay
attention to politics I'm like dude I
have little respect for that because you
can't complain about why the prices are
so high and then say but I don't do
anything about it or even know why or no
why your complaints there they mean
nothing to me yeah you come to me and be
like well my house is burning down I
have no idea what's happening I just
like lighting matches in my living room
I'm flick him onto the floor and I'm
like okay well maybe that's what caused
your problem maybe you did a thing and
you're not paying attention to it and
you burned your house down
oh go ahead I'm sorry no that's it that
you keep voting they keep voting for
this I was surprised in the video that
you can repossess someone's braces yeah
that is sort of fascinating to me well I
think the issue is they have to get
taken off and so she has to choose to
pay to have them removed or go into like
default go into debt from the
maintenance of it yeah I did always
wonder that though like for any of these
procedures or like Invisalign or any of
this if you run installment plans what
happens if you don't pay it they repo
they repo they repo your braces or your
retainer I I don't think that's what it
is I think the doctor is more than happy
to leave the braces on your mouth
indefinitely because screw you can't pay
oh and she's saying I can't afford this
so we have to stop so we have to stop
and get them taken off oh okay right
yeah it's like a long you know I I
battled this in 2020 because I was
traveling the country campaigning for
vice president and I would talk to
people who go yeah you know things are
bad but if they could just you know get
us reliable checks and I was trying to
explain to them like okay what's
happening right now is they've
essentially shut down production for the
most part and they're going to print out
ridiculous amounts of the currency that
you use every day to buy things and
they're going to hand it to you but in
doing so they're also going to hand a
bunch off to the multi-trillion dollar
companies at the same time and they're
going to get the Lion's Share of it but
in doing so they're going to greatly
expand the amount of of currency without
adding value they're actually taking way
value by making you stay home so you
have more money chasing fewer goods and
services and in very short order once
things begin to turn back to normal
you're going to see shortages you're
going to see supply chain issues and
yeah you're going to see rapid price
inflation because price inflation is
just an extension of monetary inflation
and that's what we've seen and you know
you had a handful of people in DC like
Thomas Massey and and Justin Amash and a
handful of others who were speaking out
against this everyone else either
because they wanted it or because they
were afraid to go against the corporate
media narrative about it they went along
with it and we're now suffering the
consequences of it and to be fair uh I
was uh more in line with the uh with
Trump spend the money figure it out and
I think hindsight being 2020 we now
realized the mistake that was but I
think for the most part too many of us
trusted the machine when it said we were
dealing with the deadly pandemic we all
we saw these videos coming out of China
and I think good people tried to be good
people and said look you know like these
people collapsing it's terrifying now we
look back and we're like okay it was bad
but like man did they over hype this and
drive us into the ground over nonsense
and the real reason was probably
political control well they also hid
Origins right yeah I still do they still
they still do and and the thing is we're
not we aren't quite at Smoking Gun
Territory yet but we're at like the
smell of gunpowder territory it's like I
mean we're we're getting there where we
are here's what we already know
the uh the NIH funded Echo Health
Alliance you creating using gain of
function research to greatly increase
the the function and to humanize viruses
that were at least the one that we know
of is at least I think either 96 or 98
uh genetically similar to the virus that
creates Cova 19 SARS Cove 2. um so we
don't have that Smoking Gun yet but it
was at the Wuhan lab that it happened at
and as soon as anyone even asked a
question about it they were called
racist racist because that's that led me
to start saying everything was racist
like you know my son would be like Mom
can we go to Walmart and I'd be like
that's right that's right I can't do
that at all and we have spaghetti for
dinner that's not racist here's like the
one thing I always make for dinner
here's what's wild about that they were
saying gain a function research that's
racist it's because Chinese people were
eating bats right and you're like oh
okay hold on there that sounds racist to
me right well we uh no one's ever
accused them of not being Hypocrites so
fair enough no that's actually true
you've got segregationist Ally Joe Biden
in there the man who is famous for in
the 19 the the crime Bill uh the uh in
the 1970s okay four segregation had
ended at what like several years prior
to that at that point and he was saying
he was in an interview he said that he
he had an issue with integration because
he feared that his children were going
to grow up in a racial jungle right with
Corn Pops yes
no no I yeah I got a couple theories
about Corn Pop on this one too one
this is a long time ago this is back
like how old was Joe Biden in the Corn
Pop story this segregation area uh yeah
yeah yeah so I'm wondering if Corn Pop
was a black dude and the real issue that
Joe Biden had with him was his race
here's you know a guy who's not supposed
to be here I also think the simpler
answer is that Joe Biden told the story
about how little kids were rubbing his
legs I bet corn Papa was like Hey you
creep get get off them kids well even by
any calls it a chain and he's like
what'd you say to him I was gonna say
even by his own story it started because
he was making fun of the black man's
hair the guy got upset and so he
responded by threatening to hang him
with a chain
like this is his story yes this is this
is the Democratic incumbent this is this
endearing lynching story Jesus it's Joe
Biden's endearing lynching story minutes
moments or earlier that day where he
talked about how he would force black
children's uh faces under the water so
they could stroke his legs or whatever
it was like yeah this is a great story
Joe like what's very busy that's why I
kind of think that Corn Pop probably saw
him doing that because that's part of
the story is like the kids I got hairy
legs yeah the kids would rub my leg they
loved it yeah they loved him there's a
cartoon of that creep that is so nasty
it's so weird it's not like he has a
history of slipping children's hair
we've all been kids did you ever feel
compelled to rub somebody's leg a
strange man's legs
here I'll play oh there's the video yeah
yeah yeah I got her
hair turned
my old species
and rub my leg down so it was traded and
then watch the hair come back up again
they look at it so I learned about
roaches I learned about oh yeah he
called them roaches yeah no called black
children kids jumping on my lap yeah
maybe Corn Pop was just mad that he was
calling black children roaches like I
mean the entire the entirety of that
story there is nothing about it that
isn't creepy or racist and it was
presented as wholesome family this is a
great story this video is like from a
few years ago yeah this was on the
campaign Trail
he was calling little blackheads roaches
yes he said he loves roaches in that
clip yeah but I think everyone was like
what is this person talking about who
even knows I didn't even know this is
what he was calling that that's what
because you know
approaches I had no idea this is where
he told the Corn Pop story right yes
okay
well there you go Joe Biden's racist
news at 11. yeah
yeah the whole time like that's what so
interesting about hearing like someone
recite it and be like and then he said
this crazy thing and they said this
crazy thing and it's like oh wait he has
been open about this the entire time and
somehow they have repackaged him enough
to get him to the presidency like that's
the craziest part of me what I think is
really wild too is that we keep having
all of this stuff come out about Hunter
Biden about his foreign business
relations about how Joe Biden was on
speakerphone calls right he was on
speakerphone calls with uh Executives of
burisma uh you know saying like hey hey
Dad these guys could use our help you
know and by being like okay that sounds
great you know
pleasantries and then get off the phone
um we keep seeing all of this stuff we
see the documents from Comer that come
out we see like all of this about all of
this potential bribery stuff and it just
doesn't seem to make a dent anywhere it
doesn't seem to like impact the culture
at large it doesn't seem to like get any
kind of foothold and I was listening to
another one of these stupid podcasts and
and then that's our industry right
um and they were saying that uh the
David Weiss investigation into 100 right
of course because the attorney general
who foiled the investigation is now the
special counsel for the investigation
they were saying that David Weiss would
be unlikely to use any of the
information dug up by Congress because
it would be irrelevant to his case
how is that possibly irrelevant that the
president and his son took like 10
million dollar bribe and it's traceable
because they're nice guys hey because
he's got hairy legs he's got hairy legs
and kids love them mansion and Malibu
yeah I I the thing that frustrated one
of the things that frustrated me the
most during the Trump presidency was you
know when he got elected or shortly
before he got elected he found out or we
all found out that Obama's FBI had been
spying on him explicitly to try to make
sure that he could get basically what
they're doing now to prosecute him so he
couldn't run any be in prison and um so
he knew that now he's in office then
while he's in office they do the Steele
dossier they do all the the so-called PP
Story the golden shower story they do
all this stuff to not just discredit
them but to try to now try them
essentially for treason and to impeach
him for that and I thought here it comes
this man's been talking about smashing
the Deep State I've been advocating for
the abolition of the FBI for quite some
time it's going to happen and then he
would sign off on Omnibus Bill after
Omnibus Bill that gave them even more
funding than they had gotten previously
and then you would hear like you know
when something would happen like the
chaos that was happening during some of
the riots and he would call for like
federalizing the police response and it
was like you're not getting man like
it's not they're not just against you
this system is a bad system that needs
to be smashed you said you were going to
do it you were elected at least in part
you were elected because you weren't
Hillary Clinton but you were elected at
least in part because you said you were
going to smash the system wins that I
feel like I'm that Meme where I'm poking
with a stick and saying you know come on
get do this system smashing and I I I
hate possum yeah awesome yeah just
please come on you know smash the system
and even now he's not calling for for
anything let's talk about this story we
have this from the post ammonia we have
a lot of post mail tonight huh former
Ukrainian prosecutor Victor shoken
confirms he was fired after Joe Biden
demanded it now a couple years ago there
was a sworn affidavit from Victor shoken
where he attested to just this but now
we have him giving a a public statement
on this where he spoke to Fox News and
he outright uh yeah so that's your story
Libby why don't you tell us what Evan
Yeah so basically Victor shoken went on
with Brett Bear and he confirmed that he
was told when he got fired that it was
Joe Biden's wish that he'd be fired
let's slow down real quick there may be
a lot of people who have no idea who
this guy is do you want me to do like a
hole Yeah I think I'll just give you the
general the general gist and then you
can take it away yeah Joe Biden flew to
Ukraine said I will illegally withhold
agency illegal he said I will withhold
Aid a billion dollars unless you fire a
prosecutor this is the the Crux of the
whole argument either against Trump
demanding his impeachment or against Joe
Biden for being corrupt Victor shulkin
is the guy who got fired he is saying he
got fired because Joe Biden demanded it
and Joe Biden likely took bribes anyway
yeah so I was going to look up the story
but I'm just going to go from memory
because my Google isn't working you
definitely remember all the details
um yeah so basically Victor shoken was a
prosecutor who was investigating
beerisma he was investigating barisma
because he was concerned that they were
doing illegal energy deals and who who
is brisma purisma is a Ukrainian Energy
company on Whose Board Hunter Biden sat
he was getting 83 000 a month uh his
business partner Devin Archer was also
on the board they were getting this
money they don't have any expertise in
energy burismo was interested in
entering the U.S market they were under
investigation in Ukraine which makes it
tough to enter a U.S market at that
point because you're already looked at
as kind of 80. so basically what
happened was the CEO of burisma signed
on Hunter Biden and Devin Archer to help
them with the the U.S market slash get
influence through then VP Joe Biden so
Joe Biden knew the burisma guys there
were meetings with you know he met them
he ended up on phone calls with them at
these meetings uh Victor shoken was the
prosecutor tasked with investigating
that Joe Biden
um was the White House
um he was the guy for the White House
overseeing Ukraine during the Obama
Administration so there had been a
billion dollars in loan guarantees that
were approved for Ukraine
Joe Biden was meant to go to Ukraine
deliver the loan guarantees he said I'm
going to withhold this money unless you
fire shoken he said this to Petro
poroshenko who was zelenski's
predecessor so he said this poroshenko
was like uh oh okay shoken is totally
fired now and we'll take the money Joe
Biden then went on a panel it was
televised and he bragged about this he
told this story just as eloquently as he
told that Corn Pop leg hair story uh he
went on he's not hiding anything no he
was very proud of what he had done
claiming that shoken was corrupt and
that they got their own guy in there so
okay that is a thing that happened then
Donald Trump in July 2019 Joe Biden had
announced her presidency in April of
that year Donald Trump makes a phone
call to then you know president
zielinski who had replaced poroshenko
and he says Hey we've got this money
coming for you I think it was 391
million dollars way less than a billion
by the way uh we have this money coming
for you uh Congress has approved it
that's cool but also I'm interested to
know uh what impact Joe Biden had on the
firing of Victor shoken
um was he involved you know let's sort
of hash that out uh that phone call was
recorded it was leaked the transcript of
that was leaked and then in um you know
the the media had a field day with it
Donald Trump is withholding funds from
Ukraine unless they investigate Joe
Biden so then Congress brings him up on
impeachment charges claiming that he had
withheld funds for his own personal gain
that he had uh committed election
interference by asking Ukraine to
publicly investigate Joe Biden over the
firing of shoken which Biden had already
said he'd done they accused him and
impeached him of election interference
months and months and months before the
election so they said okay Trump you're
impeached because you asked for an
investigation into Biden for something
that he publicly said that he did and
you wanted more details now he's being
prosecuted for all of this stuff
um and that's not being considered
election interference I was going to say
if only he had ordered uh prosecutors to
prosecute Joe Biden right and have the
the trial date start right before super
Tuesday then it would not be election
interference so that's what they that's
what they impeached him over and if you
read the impeachment documents which I
did yesterday it's very detailed about
how uh Trump was wrong to launch an
investigation into a political opponent
during an election year yeah well I mean
come on to be fair I don't think you
guys have actually read any of the laws
that they're using to to go after Trump
on for the you know when they impeached
him it clearly states that in uh in the
instance that the accused is Republican
the full force of the law shall be you
know levied against this individual
however if said accused as Democrat then
just forget about it that's actually in
the law it's okay when we do a
progressive 36-16 or whatever exactly
all of this and more at Tim Cass you
which is going to be launching later
this year
yes yes exactly I am a doctor yes and we
declared it publicly tonight I never
said the universe that was actually
something I should say a long time ago
uh I would be happy to accredit this I'm
willingness into existence I have a PhD
from the University so I could I think
we just made the board I would make the
point of circular accreditation right
you get accredited from the University
and then found it so that it I like it
correct so I like this to explain to
people I've been explaining people
credentialism for a long time so you
know I'd be talking to these like a lot
of friends everyone's like you have to
go to college if you want to get a good
job I'll go please and then I'd be like
well I have I have a masters they'd be
like you have a masters I'm like yeah in
nuclear engineering they're like what do
you really need to be like oh yeah you
know from Milton you and they'd be like
what don't make this right yeah I made
it up it's not an accredited school or
anything but I gave it to myself I used
to want to make up wait a minute College
sweatshirts and be like no this is where
I went to school just like I want to
wear this okay I'll make you some some
some some some uh body at some
organization determines that you are
worthy and gives you a title I can give
myself whatever title I want that's like
with Jordan Peterson being uh
re-educated re-educated by the Ontario
College of Physicians because he made
some incendiary social media posts the
people who complained about Jordan
Peterson and got him investigated and
subject to re-education they were not
his clients they were not his students
they were not his patients or whatever
they were people who saw his post on the
internet and didn't like them and didn't
like them oh that's pretty serious
that's pretty serious precisely is
supposed to re-educate him the Ontario
College of physicians in fact there are
people that they have said will be the
ones doing the re-education Jordan
Peterson will be paying for it and those
Specialists those experts those
credentialed people cost 225 an hour
Prager Prager you should give out phds
if it doesn't work Jordan Peterson has
said that he's going to put it all on
YouTube well that's like live streaming
yeah it can help offset the cost that he
has to cover which I'm sure he'll make
much more than 220. it'll be great
they're gonna make it a minimum wage 48
hours and I was like yeah yeah well and
the the credentialed experts are the
ones who get to decide how long the
training will go so if they feel it's
not working they can do extensions
extend it exactly that they are getting
paid to do and that will be streamed on
you too so they've given him essentially
they've given him a
uh almost unlimited fine yeah or or are
fine with no upper limit at the very
time it's either that or they take his
license and it goes until he admits I
agree with what you think you know what
because leaves and credentials second
one I agree yeah like as soon as they
say it'd be like you're right absolutely
okay great like we don't think great to
see you we don't think you do agree he's
like no no I totally agree he would say
something else I agree yeah I don't
think he'd ever do that I don't know I
think Peterson's going to be alive screw
off your dang marxists but it wouldn't
be funny if he's like no I already
minded no like he's gonna argue with
them yeah for sure he's gonna put it on
YouTube it's gonna be hilarious he's
gonna wear what if he changes their mind
live
what if he under educate or well so it's
funny
under educated have you guys you've
heard about like the FBI agents who were
tasked with monitoring right-wing
message boards started becoming right
wing I totally believe it yeah they're
like they're seeing all these posts and
then they're going like wait a minute I
told this stuff I was wrong and I wasn't
supposed to talk about it but when I
read through it they're making some good
oh a good points my goal is to get my
NSA mind for there to be churn in the
NSA because they keep having to assign
new people to me because they go
oh no yeah oh he's right crap he's right
and then they have to quit or whatever
maybe they'll just you know smash no
what happened what happens is is like
the uh the NSA has a they know that the
assignment to spike is like a three
month rotation and so they tell they
tell the agent like it's a three-month
rotation just so you know like watch
three months like typically we do two
years like just trust us and then after
like two and a half months the guy's
sitting there and he's like shaking he's
got a cigarette and he's going back and
forth like he's right about everything
man he's right about everything and
they're like all right time to get him
out of there we all have to go like
through mandatory meetings with the
psychologist afterwards who's like no no
I'm not a doctor
they have to put him through the
re-education program yeah they have to
put them through Jordan that's these
people are good that are going to be
doing Jordan Peterson they're the ones
that have to deprogram the my NSA
minders into like re-believing they have
to re-blue pill them
I always thought that was weird about
like phds like you have to go defend
your thesis but what if I don't respect
anyone who's on the panel what if I
don't like any of their these I'm
questioning your Authority yeah I don't
understand I've always found it weird
the credentialism and the people
insisting that they're a doctor and so
forth because I was proud to tell people
I barely made it out of high school like
I didn't go to college and I had
multiple successful businesses and you
know create life my wife's like super
hot and everything and I'm like you know
like why why would I I like being able
to say that I got this despite the fact
that the schooling system tried to keep
me down hard work is hard that's why
it's called hard work right and often
hard work actually it's possible I
should say this hard work isn't often
always hard sometimes it's tedious yes
time consuming yeah but I think it's
it's a class thing right like well well
the issue is this if you can work hard
you can make a lot of money but if you
want to party take out loans and then
get your degree and then say look I did
a thing that's why they that it's I
think college is the lazy route to be
completely honest
so if you look at somebody who gets out
of high school or doesn't go to high
school and they start working start a
business even if the job is Starbucks or
McDonald's and they work their way to
becoming a manager uh what is it like
the CEO of UPS started as like a uh in
the Sorting room or something like that
there's a bunch of stories like that
that's the perfect job to start in the
mail room started as an intern that's
that's the hard way you start working
you work hard you get smart and you try
and figure out along the way you become
the best at it for a lot of people they
are tricked into going to college
they're told it's the only way to do it
but I also know for a fact that a lot of
these people go to college knowing that
it's vacation they're going to get a big
loan they're going to go party every
night they're going to barely do any
work they're going to get a piece of
paper that says I deserve a job then
they're going to demand the government
pay their loans back and that's what a
lot of them are doing so why do they
want these degrees and everything it's
because they didn't actually earn any
real Authority but they're the experts
now so they get to assert that yeah so
I'll tell you this who it's you ever
seen that movie
um with Rodney Dangerfield what is it
called like back to school or something
with Robert Downey Jr and yeah yeah and
there's like that scene where I haven't
seen this in decades but is it scene
where he's in the classroom and the
professor is explaining the basics of
like marketing and like selling widgets
he's like what are you talking about
that doesn't make any sense and then
everyone turns to him and starts taking
notes from him because he says ultra
wealthy businessman like he knows how to
sell widgets yeah who would you rather
get advice from a guy who built a high
school dropout who built a record label
yeah or a university Professor is
teaching people how to do music
management yeah and that's the problem
with schools but I accept him cast you
that's true
Tim cast you is proudly minority owned
from an underprivileged uh upgrade a man
from a mixed race person from an under
privileged upbringing a high school
dropout who built it from the ground up
and will will credential you if uh you
ask yeah and the first the first PhD is
a woman so that's so true a pre-phd
already credentialed from them yeah yeah
I think part of it is a lot of the
University system especially when you
get to like the ivy League's more Elite
schools it functions the way that when
you're in middle school and there's a
brand that everyone wears and so if you
have the brand what was that brand when
you were in Middle School I feel like it
was Abercrombie and Fitch when I was
growing up like that was the thing that
if like you had the Hollister
Abercrombie stuff then like you were
cool right I did not uh it wasn't like
Aeropostale no of course not don't be a
popper Olivia no I'm just kidding but if
I if I can look at you but I went to
Princeton I went to Harvard right I get
to say that I am Elite in some way and
therefore I deserve something that you
guys don't have right that's what I find
that I'll get into you know arguments
about you know books or whatever with
someone and they'll be like well my mom
told me this about the book and she went
to Princeton and I don't care that
doesn't mean it doesn't mean anything
because they are they aren't trading on
their brains or their actual
accomplishment or intellectual ability
they're trading on the brand name of
what they paid or realistically went to
huge amounts of debt for and to shatter
that illusion is very hard for them I
mean that but shattering the illusion is
I think a big part of what we're talking
about right because I think that a lot
of the people who are having trouble
dealing with the society where
credentials are actually not really that
valid or who are looking at you know the
whole situation with Trump and realizing
like perhaps like that he is not
actually guilty of all these things or
looking at Biden and saying oh he is
guilty of all of these things or seeing
Society crumble or all of the looting or
the stores closing down or all of this
stuff it's like it's very difficult to
let go of what you thought our country
was and what you thought our culture was
about so you look at it and you say why
are people looting the stores you know
and that's really not that's really not
the right question at this point like
things have changed so drastically and
so many people just want to hang on to
the art the idea the expectation of what
they had for our culture and our country
and it's very difficult to let that go
you know I mean you can grieve what that
was but like we have to let it go to a
certain extent we're gonna go to super
chats so if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
share with your friends and if you go to
timcast.com you can see the timcast
Miami show ticket sales are now
available we hope to see you there it's
gonna be really fun we got a bunch of
gifts to give away sponsored by Public
Square we're huge fans Patrick Bet David
Donald Trump Jr Matt Gates hosted by me
and of course Luke gradkowski it is
going to be an amazing night and uh
there may be some other stuff because
the event is actually longer than just
IRL so we're hoping to do a q a audience
only session should be really fun and
funny and um even a pre-show we're
working those details out we'll announce
them shortly but it's gonna be a fun
show let's grab your super chats by the
Fireside says if Trump is in court super
Tuesday his campaign should hold free
Trump rallies in the Battleground States
and have as many social media pro-trump
figures as possible speak in his Stead
entirely possible that's one thing to
consider too they want to shut him down
on super Tuesday but he still has
powerful prominent media voices
personality circuits Etc who can go
around rallying and campaigning on his
behalf and the trial may actually hurt
them in this regard because it justifies
a lot it exemplifies a lot of what Trump
has been saying so if you get Trump Jr
if you get uh Dan bongino out on the
campaign Trail if they go out and they
say look what they are doing to this man
they are cheating that that could be
more powerful than Trump himself yeah
especially since then he could justify
not being you know super Tuesday you
want to be in 800 places at once whereas
he could send every member of his family
everyone who represents him and say you
know he would be here he would be in
this spot except that they're keeping
him there in 12 States
it's like looking at like if you have a
bunch of kids and you're like you're
you're my favorite slash you're all my
favorite you know I may have done him a
favor with this they I think the thing
that I I can't get over the fact that
within what two hours the Trump campaign
had those mug shot merch read ready to
go oh we had it too at post millennial
we had we had t-shirts ready to go I
bought two of them but that's what I
mean during the show we made the Revenge
poster and put a t-shirt up yeah and we
sold it I saw that and you know what
that morning I was like the mug shot we
need to like talk about the mug shot and
comparing it to the Obama Shepard Ferry
and then you did it and I was like nice
yeah it was so funny and then but that's
the thing this campaign has just
embraced that this is happening right
they're saying like it's so ludicrous we
now fundraise off of it so I think
actually fundraising off it yeah
everyone's gonna fundraise off it but I
think Trump is the most successful and I
really think being able to say like I
would be here in whatever state except I
can't so I sent to you my sons or
whoever it's powerful I I think that
this in a way breed life into his
campaign because I remember this time
last year people were talking about
maybe this isn't Trump's time anymore
maybe it's DeSantis turn look at all the
stuff he's done in in uh and I'm saying
in Republican circles I'm a Libertarian
we were having a completely different
conversation but in Republic in circles
they're saying look at the stuff he's
done in Florida uh you know Trump just
wants to keep relitigating 2020 maybe
he's not because I feel like he was
really better yeah and some of the polls
were showing that that head-to-head
DeSantis would do better against Biden I
would have told them that's because
DeSantis is largely an unknown compared
to Trump and they always do better that
way um but then with this it's like no
Trump's the candidate now which is why
again I don't think they're looking at
the politics of it I think they want to
put him in prison I do too but that's I
felt like after his CNN Town Hall where
he was just like the most ridiculous and
also best version of himself where he's
like describing this case I bought
against him he's like I own the hotel
across the street you think I will oh
the CNN Town Hall yes exactly and you
know I think to your point too there was
a moment where people really doubted it
and that's why CNN was like it's fine
we'll have this town hall and we'll
destroy him and he is proving time and
time again that he he is ready and
willing to go into this very uh
aggressive attack on him personally
right we got this from X headshot X I
have to want I wonder if the RNC and
Ronald McDaniel is supporting the dnc's
effort to fix the Republican primary
I won't be surprised never trumpers they
hate Trump that's why they're called
Never trumpers so uh
I don't know how many how many
Republicans in Georgia are against Trump
I mean I'm unhappy with the RNC I've
voiced my uh frustrations about Larry
Elder being kept from the debate State
and I think that's indicative of the
fact that they are controlling narrative
that they want on stage and they they
don't actually want Trump there despite
Ronald Daniels being like it would be
wrong for him to miss it they only
wanted the fact that he could bring in a
large audience they they know that he
will not comply with whatever they want
hence the Loyalty pledge uh and they
kept it Larry Elder out which means that
there's a whole lot of conversation that
would have been the Loyalty pledge is
pretty standard I mean they do that yeah
but Trump was never going to sign a
loyalty pledge you should be here except
we're offering the stipulation that you
know we know that proudly refused to do
it in 2016. I remember it was funny
because it was kind of a when when the
thing happened with vivec when they
asked uh you know would you would you
pardon Trump I think that was the
question yeah and he immediately raised
his hands all the way up and and slipped
around and was like yeah but just look
around he's like
that look around was deadly worse than
the Howard Dean thing when he died that
was a thousand it was worse than when
Dukakis got in the tank it was worse
than when Gary uh Johnson asked what
Aleppo was like it's it's it completely
eliminated that humility but it was a
call back to kind of the opposite of
that when in this would have been in
2015 during the first I think the first
Republican debate they said uh you know
who here would not support is not
willing to agree to support whoever the
Republican nominee is and Donald Trump
put up his hand proudly yeah and and no
one else would do it and I think those
are the moments where you have this big
field of candidates and one sets
themselves apart and again I don't think
uh if they are considering the political
ramifications they're idiots I don't
think they are I think that they just
want them in prison sorry I was gonna
read more Super chats all right Brendan
that's important tiersma says just got
hired as an intern for Turning Point USA
Today thank you for helping to get the
job with your content and now I can help
fight the culture War here's another way
you can up by the culture war with more
information information to come move to
Martinsburg West Virginia we look we
look forward to seeing you there uh we
are uh I'll keep things a little light
for now until we get things going but uh
I look forward to anybody who is anybody
who is looking to get away from their
cities is trying to find a place to live
Martinsburg West Virginia is a good spot
for people who love this country and uh
there's a lot of good people there but
it is in I'll put it this way in West
Virginia Martinsburg has some
interesting elements in it and I think
there's an opportunity for us to do
really really great things in this uh in
this town and they could use they could
use help they could use investment and
we are going to be investing in this
area we're not just in Martinsburg but
uh we're going to be setting up some
some some stuff going on there you can
infer uh whatever you want with that but
uh I hope I hope to see you down there
and if you and if you live in
Martinsburg every day you can drive by
ATF headquarters and flip them off is
that where they are that's true no way
yeah I did a machine gun shoot in
Martinsburg last year and afterwards
they're like oh by the way the ATF
headquarters like right there
I think if I remember this correctly the
one in Martinsburg has so many documents
that the floor was collapsing I could be
misremembering the story there was some
crazy amount of documents that they were
storing there which of course I find
sketchy for the UTF but well we got some
projects is it because Biden has an
office there well I feel safer when Joe
Biden is around he just you know he lets
kids rub his legs and he falls on
bicycles if any if any black men are
around threatens to hang them with a
chain it's nauseating all right let's
read more Teddy D says Tim sent up the
salmon signal and Spike showed up yes
Spike Cohen 2024 yes but the I'm I'm
announcing tonight no I'm not I I've
become a a meme for my my um I'll call
it an addiction I'm a former drug addict
and I'm a salmon addict I can't not eat
I've already eaten salmon toys delicious
it's twice today raw or cooked uh
actually so I had a poke Bowl uh this
morning and then I had some smoked
salmon right before I came here so hot
smoke so so both raw and cooked when
does your salmon oriented uh cookbook
come out uh now uh yeah right now I'm
actually gonna have a class at Tim cast
and preparations
in all seriousness uh are we going to
ever figure out who the Libertarians
intend to is there a primary should
people DM you on Twitter about it oh
they already are um so uh it may I think
it's May 24th or 25th it's at the end of
May is when we officially pick our
nominee at the at the National
Convention our system is it like a
primary or no it's not our system works
a little differently each state has a
convention each state affiliate has a
convention where they pick their
delegates those delegates then go to the
National Convention and pick it so it's
it's going to be about like just under
600 people who ultimately will decide or
a majority of right around 600 that will
decide who the the nominee is I've not
decided yet if I'm running I haven't
ruled it out uh but ultimately it's
going to come down to how I can best
help the party in the Liberty Movement
well I've heard mutterings about people
who won't do it people who might do it
and I gotta say it's not promising
we were really excited for Dave Smith
yeah Dave just announced he wasn't
running right and now everyone's kind of
like well well come on like he he's
perfect he's great now it's who knows
May's far away maybe you guys will have
someone jump to the front you know you
never know I mean it it's it is very
early on you have to do it yeah
think about how much salmon you could
yeah so from when when I even when I was
running for VP there were you know this
sort of like slow trickle of people are
like you know you should run in 24 you
should run a 24 on the top of the ticket
and that slow trickle is kind of grown
steadily over time and then when Dave
announced he wasn't running yeah now
they're like that's like a fire hose on
me so we'll see I haven't ruled it out
but I do it's it's nothing I've I've
particularly like uh had a goal to do it
it looks like a lot of people will take
it on almost like an ego stroke where
where and that ends up being a poison
chalice when they do it if I do it it's
because I think it's the best way I can
serve the movement so right well there
is a thing like you remember George
Washington didn't necessarily want to be
present but he was pushed into Power
because the people demanded that he lead
yeah
driving around like please come on all
right the Appalachian podcast says Spike
say Appalachia Appalachia P.S Tim love
what you guys are doing for the
Appalachian region keep it up
yeah I love it out here it's uh it's
it's the best weather
we didn't have any we didn't have winter
this past year though so it's kind of
kind of a letdown because we got a big
field we wanted a snowboard in because
it's it's like it's a very light Hill
and then no snow yeah not even a little
bit I was like I was gonna snowboard oh
that's a that's a bummer but whatever we
got grapes everywhere now those are some
people you should consider having on
Simon and Billy of Appalachian podcast
some of the coolest people I've ever met
I was on their show we went to uh
Simon's Place shot off machine guns
those would be good people to have on
yeah right on sounds fun absolutely and
with me telling everybody to come to
Martinsburg West Virginia it's also uh
Jefferson and Berkeley County uh you
know good places I love Morgan County
too I mean the whole Eastern Panhandle
is a really interesting place where's
Morgan it's further West Morgan is like
if there are three counties that make up
the Easter Panhandle it's the farthest
uh is that where Berkeley Springs is
that's where Berkeley Springs is right
yeah everyone loves that place yeah it's
super cool I mean it's the oldest like
Spa town in the country or something
like that it's so cute it's super cute
uh I would also say if you guys are
interested in this music that Oliver
Anthony put out there's a song called
Appalachia by a guy named Josiah and the
bonnevilles and it gives you all the
Vibes about wanting to move to
Appalachia or away and uh look up the
history of the song uh was it Country
Roads not about West Virginia no the
word just comes up once so uh I read
about it and it was inspired by
Montgomery County Maryland but that
doesn't roll off the tongue very well so
they went and looked up in an
encyclopedia West Virginia stuff and
then wrote a song about West Virginia
instead am I wrong and thinking that
Montgomery is one of the Three Counties
in Western Maryland that was like please
let us join West Virginia they're like
yeah we would love to have you you have
to ask Baltimore and now we've heard
nothing about it also the county that
Winchester Virginia which is sits right
below the Panhandle so sort of Drive
South from Martinsburg in their uh
County Charter a Western Union state
senator told me this it has a clause
where at any point they are allowed to
secede into West Virginia because of the
way it was divided Winchester it's the
county that went down that's in Virginia
yeah they can unilaterally do that
without any that's what a West Virginia
state senator told me that you know for
when they were dividing up the state
they were like okay we're not going
right now but we may want to eventually
wow interesting because because West
Virginia came in as a slave state but
then it was only a slave state for like
16 months or something like that right
West Virginia didn't it I think it was
the opposite I think West Virginia
stained at the Union in Virginia isn't
there slavery in West Virginia I think I
I think they stay with the Union but
they were still slave state Maryland was
a slave same thing with Delaware yeah
that's what it was yeah West Virginia
was a slave state for like anything yeah
the Emancipation Proclamation was
explicitly written for the states that
were segregated so even after the Civil
War ended you know we talked about how
Juneteenth happened you know months
after or year after two years yeah in
Delaware it didn't end until like 1870
or 1870 it was multiple like what six
years after the war end wow but we don't
celebrate that anniversary all right
well I'll throw some read some more Lord
Joseph Cole says Tim take your advice
moved out of the city we are in a bind
please help us if you can give zendigo
the Kohl's family to get our power back
on oh yikes man well I hope everything
works out for you guys no one ever said
escaping and being and living is is uh
being on your own is going to be easy
and that's what I was thinking about
with that video where the woman's like I
can't afford to live this way part of me
was like man well maybe you should just
vote for politicians who are actually
going to help make your life better pay
attention what's going on in the world I
don't you know it's it's I'm sad to hear
this woman uh upset in this way but part
of me also said like what would this
woman be doing if it was 200 years ago
ain't nobody 200 years ago was driving
in their car being like I can't afford
to live it's like dude you couldn't make
it 10 miles without potentially dying
okay I'm exaggerating 100 years ago if
she was a single mom now if if 200 years
ago she was married and then got
divorced and became a single she like
she wouldn't have been doing there's no
divorce right so she still would be
married or she would have been totally
Outcast for having children out of
wedlock 200 years ago none of that would
have happened and let's be honest like
the risks to your life back then were
substantial she may have died in
childbirth or something I mean well and
and also if the reason that she's a
single mother is because the father
abandoned her and the kids uh no
Community 200 years ago would have
tolerated yeah they would that guy would
have been an outcast yeah he'd have to
run West and go be a bandito or
something and then the community would
help that help that the community would
probably around that woman exactly right
but we're in a nasty place where we have
all these luxuries but no family it is
very bizarre I keep thinking of that
Jane's Addiction song uh three days when
he says we uh
we choose no kin but adopted strangers
oh interesting what's the line yeah
all right let's grab some more Super
chats
where are we at
Steve Hagan says it looks like the step
on snack and find out means find out not
much happens please keep stepping on
snack ramp
uh well I guess unfortunately so I feel
like that sorry yeah oh the don't tread
on me Flags been on for a really really
long time and he's been trampled that
that poor little snake is long dead I
just wonder how many lockdowns were
enforced and officers would show up with
The Thin Blue Line variant of the don't
tread on you as they actively tread on
people who were you know committing
crimes like going to church and and
meeting their loved ones or in Quebec
like police would show up if there were
more than five people in your house and
they would drag people out it was
terrifying in Kentucky they they
arrested a pastor and his congregation
for having Church in the parking lot in
their own cars like they were even doing
the whole we don't know how serious this
is don't you know touch each other don't
get near each other but we get to
worship God together we're going to
worship First Amendment God in proximity
to one another we're going to stay
outside we're going to be in our own
cars or I think their windows are even
up and they were still arrested
do you remember the congregation that
held Church in Walmart in Pittsburgh oh
yeah yeah no but that's beautiful yeah
wow that's right
let's grab another Super Chat here
what is this the emperor Champion says
we should be a little bit more Warhammer
40K and a whole lot less My Little Pony
come on grow pair and at least MPG Joe
Biden yes that would be so nice
Warhammer not My Little Pony I've got a
pony still a thing we're like a weird
adult men liked My Little Pony probably
remember that for a second it was
horrifying maybe they're now just pups
in the pride pride parade I was gonna
say I think a lot of brownies may have
like moved on to like being furries or
something yeah all right just if they
have leg character just BG says we need
to educate folks on how to write in
Trump's name if he's taken off the
ballot some folks don't know they can
if they take his name off the ballot I
don't know if uh in South Carolina you
can't write in for president really nope
why uh I don't know it's the it's
whatever our rules are I went there uh
in 2016 I showed up with some crayons
and they told me that uh not only could
I not use the Crayons uh and uh not only
could I not use a pen it was a a like a
um digital yeah digital thing I was
gonna do like a protest and they're like
well not only can you not do that it's
digital but you can't write in a name
anyway you have to pick from the names
in New York you can write in and it's
still a paper ballot yeah they didn't
they didn't give that option on the day
of that was 2016 though that's rude I
thought so just Revenant says the police
and government will simply make up
reasons take your rights and put you in
prison it happened to me and I'm Joe
schmoe that's right disorderly conduct
for instance what does that even mean
you can be walking down the street
whistling a tune and they'll say hey
you're disturbing the peace and you're
under arrest in uh in South Carolina a
friend of mine named Johnny McCoy who's
an attorney uh he actually got after he
was arrested for it there was a law on
the books I forget what it was called
but basically it was so uh it was so
like vaguely defined that uh it got
struck down because when he asked why
his friend was being arrested for he was
asking what his friend was being
arrested for and they arrested him for
that oh wow yeah and it was something
like like interfering with police duties
or something like that and he literally
was saying hey what are you doing I'm an
attorney what are you what's he being
arrested for and they arrested him for
that of course they'll just make up a
reason yep you protest disorderly
conduct yeah you say it's first amount
nah you're being disorderly it's hard
not to think of Jenna Ellis who's like
arrested for being Trump's lawyer yeah
being a lawyer being doing something
completely normal and they're like no no
no lawyer straight to jail so they say
that it's a criminal conspiracy and
they're using the RICO Act are they
basically alleging that the campaign was
a criminal organization
that's right but Joe Biden's is fine a
single Republican prosecutor D.A 88 AG
or whatever anywhere has done anything
to go after Democrats in any comparable
way I find that to be absolutely
horrifying well you have Ken Paxton and
then they they're taking him out in
Texas he's well how about how about he
start filing charges here's here's one
thing
right now if they if they make any I
think uh Texas should file a lawsuit
against Georgia right now
to the Supreme Court citing original
jurisdiction saying that the federal
elections of 2024 are held between all
states and Georgia is removing a
candidate from an election that Texas
has to participate in that's a very good
point Texas should sue and say they
cannot interfere in an election because
they are negating our votes
let's go let's roll come on where we at
anybody
they could also they could also uh a
bunch of Novel Concepts how about this
well didn't we have that in the last
election weren't there some states suing
other states Texas
yeah and it was a whole 48 states versus
48 states that's right and then the
Supreme Court's like nah we're not going
to hear it we don't care the argument
was that there were state legislatures
telling Mike Pence telling Trump we did
not approve these changes to the
election the Constitution says the state
legislature has final say so we want the
chance to adjudicate this and or to
legislate this and uh Mike Pence was
like nah
and that was it and so a lot lawsuits uh
this was before that the lawsuit went
out saying like Texas said we
participate in this election and what
these what Pennsylvania has done is not
constitutional
so it is voiding our participation and
we demand this be heard and the Supreme
Court said not interested and then you
ended up with States asking Mike Pence
to intervene because of the unilateral
changes that were made in violation of
the Constitution and he was like are you
crazy they showed me a picture of JFK
and then he ran away screaming and
crying like a little baby well because
JFK they had the alternate electors in
Hawaii with Nixon and Nixon rejected the
certified electors that's right how
about that
and that's what the forgery is when
they're Prosecuting for forgery in
Georgia the forgery is signing off on
Alternate slates of electors just like
the Democrats did in 1960s just like
them how about that and then in 1961
when they were counting the votes
Richard Nixon says we've got the
certified Republican votes but everyone
agree with you to the Democrats instead
all right Democrats instead and that was
it but it's not even that it was that
they were asking Mike Pence to return
the the votes and and not reject them
out like it wasn't they were being
rejected they would go back to the
States the states would figure it out
but it would still trigger the house
delegations electing the president right
and Mike Pence is
he's like
a listless vessel you know it's a good
way he's kind of like and he's an NPC
you know he's like a very strong NPC
like he has this new line that he'll say
that uh you know I'm very proud of the
the work I did with President trump it
did not end well and it's like it's in
his book he'll say it in interviews he
said it probably like 300 times now and
he'll say every time thinking it's going
to land just as hard as the first time
he didn't it's like he doesn't have
original thoughts he's such a romantic
political figure that like he's he's
just reciting things he's not thinking
he's fearful right like he wants to stay
in the good graces of whatever
establishment he thinks will protect him
if anything happens he's not willing to
take any risks like when Vivek throws
his hand in the air I was like God
pardon Trump there's a boldness there
that I just think Mike Pence doesn't
have let's read some more Chris S says
nuke of the whales
all right Nelson uh appreciate it
Simpson's reference
all right summer Andre says don't forget
the two Republican council members
killed in New Jersey oh man that's right
yeah wow
and then it's funny when you know I I
just when I talk to people about a fear
of civil war or the state of civil
Strife I hear the exact same thing
there's not enough people to engage in
this and it's just like every time I'm
like how many people do you think
like wanted Civil War how many how many
how many people do you think were
actually fighting in the American
Revolution very very few it's between
three and ten percent yeah the really
fighting in the revolution interesting
and and what what like the general
sentiment from historians is that the
public was split on the revolution yeah
whether it was a good idea or not yeah
there's that famous quote where I'm not
sure if who said it they said John Adams
something that it was 30 wanted 30 don't
30 don't care that's not true it was
more so that
um I read a historical assessment that
said something like it was like 35
support something like 23 opposed and
the rest were like don't know don't care
so they're like it wasn't the majority
but the plurality were just like we have
no idea what's going on we don't want to
know and imagine having the government
so little involved in your life that you
don't care who's in charge of it yeah
like how great is that how awesome is
that that forget you don't care who gets
elected you don't even care like who's
in charge of the gut like what the
government even is because it's it's so
not involved in your day-to-day life you
don't even care about that here's a
crazy one undermine says a single fuel
pellet smaller than an inch contains
more energy than a ton of coal or 150
gallons of oil I'm assuming you're
talking about Fusion
it's going to be Bonkers if they can if
they can like really get Fusion going
and imagine if they can even miniaturize
it and make smaller reactors and plus we
got solid state batteries wow it's gonna
be nuts if yeah I'm I'm curious how they
do propulsion without chemical energy
like I'm I'm interested to see the
that's interesting well so uh escaping
uh orbit
achieving orbit yeah there's a bunch of
different ways that's been proposed
there's one we use we use you know
chemical fuels liquid solid propulsion
for a rocket yeah one of the proposed
ways is a uh like a magnetic slingshot
railgun
that is a it's a it's a big machine
basically that takes the cargo load and
Spins it at a high rate of speed until
it's spinning as fast as possible and
then it flings it up a tube and just
launches it straight into space
that's wild yep and once you have
propulsion from uh hydrogen Fusion once
you have that now not only can you have
much further and faster space travel but
you can have the kind of stuff you see
in the Sci-Fi movies where it's like
gravity's being uh simulated because it
will um it will continue to accelerate
accelerate at what 9.8 meters per second
or whatever so that it simulates Gravity
by going in that direction and then and
then turning around and doing the
opposite to slow down that's right and
so not only will you be able to get to
Mars in a matter of hours instead of
weeks now you won't even have to deal
with the effects on your bones and
muscles of not having gravity during
that time yeah so we're like that close
to this kind of stuff that's so cool
that's the funny thing that people you
know in Sci-Fi movies they show they'll
Show the ship and then there'll be a big
ring spinning yep and they'll be like
that's how we simulate gravity they know
yeah the ship is speeding up until it
reaches halfway point and then turns
around yep so I love it because flat
earthers think that's what Earth is
doing they think Earth is permanently
accelerating forward and so that pins
you to the ground that's what gravity is
weird yep and they also think there's a
dome over our flat planet and there's an
ice wall and a whole bunch of other
crazy the firmament yeah this is Pro
Flat Earth show I was told okay
I was on a plane and this guy like
sitting next to me suddenly engaging in
conversation and heard I was a full-on
flat earther
we're on the play
tended to be a flatterer for earther
just for meme purposes from like 2015 to
2018 until my wife came into a room one
time and I was literally making a flat
Earth meme in a Facebook Flat Earth
group and she said please stop like
she's like my like our loved ones are
worried I keep assuring them this is
just a big joke they're saying how could
you do this for three that's okay fine
I'll drop the Flat Earth all right
everybody three years is commitment
yes all right everybody if you haven't
already please uh smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends if you really do like
it and head over to timcast.com click
join us become a member the members only
show is about to start and this one's
gonna get naughty we got a lot of really
nasty stuff to talk about so we're gonna
talk about in the members show and it's
time to put the kids to bed because uh
they probably don't want to hear this
but you can also get your tickets to the
timcast Miami event on the timcast page
you can follow the show at timcast IRL
you can follow me personally at timcast
everywhere you can follow me on X or
Instagram Spike do you want to shout
anything out yeah sure I'm Spike Cohen
on all social media you can find me on
there and if you want to join the
fastest growing part of the Liberty
Movement go to you are thepower.net and
if you want this cyber bully the
government shirt I'm wearing you can go
to you are thepower.net cyber all
proceeds go to help you with the power
right on and you know follow him so you
know when his salmon related cookbook is
coming out because that's really why
you're here uh I'm Hannah Claire Brimley
I'm a writer for timcast.com you should
follow at timcast news on Twitter which
I guess is called X now and Instagram uh
there's a ton of cool work there from
Oliver journalists and and a lot of
video stuff ends up on Twitter so check
that out if you want to follow me
personally I'm on Twitter at HC brimlow
and on Instagram at Hannah Duppy thank
you guys so much I'm Libby Emmons I'm at
Libby Emmons on Twitter you can see all
the great work we're doing at
thepostmillennial.com and
humanevents.com and I just want to
encourage all of you guys to become
members at thepostmillennial.com
subscribe we are always working hard to
bring you on a straightforward good
journalism and we could use all the
support that you can offer and you can
come see what we're doing there
and I am search.com uh please be nice to
Kellen for the next week uh while I'm
gone I'll be back on Friday for the
Friday show so cheers guys right on we
will see all of you over at timcast.com
in just a few minutes thanks for hanging
out